So Leute, heute machen wir nix im Stream, gar nix im Stream waren wir heute.
Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht so genau warum, das ist äußerst schlechtes Timing und ich bin
nicht ganz sicher ob ich irgendwie Anfang einer Erkältung eingefangen habe oder sowas.
Aber ich hab mir tut's ja gestern da Kopfweh und das ist ziemlich schlecht für Battlefield Release.
Also das ist gar nicht so 11 Head.
Ich hoffe mal das bis morgen wieder besser ist.
Das Game geht ja schon morgen früh on, morgen früh direkt spielen kann ich nicht,
aber später dann. Also das ist echt dummes Timing.
Aber ich kann halt eh nix großartig machen, ich nehm ja auch äußerst ungern Kopfweh-Tabletten,
weiß nicht ob ich das euch schon mal erzählt hab, aber weiß nicht irgendwie.
Ich nehm eigentlich keine Pillen gerne, ich nehm echt nur Pillen wenn ich muss.
Ja soweit schon, außer dass ich übel Kopfweh hab und hoffe dass das morgen bis Battlefield
Release oder also bis ich Battlefield spielen kann wieder weg ist.
Deswegen machen wir heute auch nix großartiges.
Was für n'n Ding? Ich weiß noch nicht mal was das ist.
Ja ich weiß auf der Xbox ist schon raus.
Aber die ganzen Videos auf dem PC die ihr seht von Battlefield,
die sind von einem Capture Event was glaube
ich Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch war.
Ja deswegen seht ihr schon die ganzen PC Gameplays, wie gesagt ihr habt ja ne Anspielevent.
Ihr habt mich nicht eingeladen, ich hab die glaub ich zu viel geflamed,
aber es juckt mich nicht großartig.
Das diet der Tachter, das macht es jetzt auch nicht aus.
Dafür muss ich keine Sellout Videos machen, wobei ich mach doch, ich mach 3 Battlefield
Sellout Videos, aber im Prinzip mach ich normale Battlefield Videos,
weil ich mein Spielmodi zeigen und so wollte ich eh.
Und wenn das EA sponsoren will, könnt ihr das gerne sponsoren, Stonks.
Die Dislike Anzeige ist schon weg, wirklich bei mir ist sie noch da.
Zeig mal kurz her.
Wir refreshen mal, mal gucken ob die weg ist.
Nee hier ist sie noch da, guckt.
Hier ist sie noch da.
Ich glaube das ist YouTube, die rollen das wieder verzögert aus.
Ja ja Max ist gut, noch ist es da, wir refreshen mal anonym, ohne Cache, Disable Cache.
Kann YouTube mal laden, die bläht überhaupt nicht, lul.
Noch ist es da, noch ist es da, aber das ist typische YouTube Geschichte,
die machen das immer zeitlich versetzt, das nicht alles.
Also ich hab ja insofern vielleicht noch eine ganz, ganz, ganz kleine Hoffnung,
weil der Aufschrei ist schon relativ groß, übrigens hier guck mal.
Ich glaube das ist mein beliebtester, beliebtester Tweet aller Zeiten.
Ah fuck, hier.
Guck mal ich steh sogar relativ weit oben.
Ah das buggt wieder rum.
Ja ich tauch da irgendwann drinnen auf und ich hab total viele Comments auf Englisch
gekriegt heute, weil die meinen Comment gelesen haben.
Guck mal hier, meine Güte, Twitter, fuck mischt doch nicht so ab.
Ja guck mal, guck mal Leute, ich glaub das ist eines meiner, meiner best, best gelikedesten
Tweets aller Zeiten, einfach nur das ich auf YouTube geantwortet hab, ich meine witzig
das YouTube mir geantwortet hat, ne auf Twitter.
Was eigentlich witzig ist, YouTube antwortet normalerweise selten, aber hier drunter haben
sie es halt mal geantwortet, man muss halt sagen, das Video, wir können uns das ja gleich
mal zusammen angucken und dann sag ich nochmal warum ich es nicht gut finde, aber ich hab
halt einfach nur relativ nett, so nett wie man das schreiben kann, drunter geschrieben
was ich denke dazu, ja ich denke das ist, also das ist die mit Abstand schlechteste Entscheidung
auf YouTube der letzten Jahre, es gab schon viele fragwürdige Dinge ja, vom einstellen
des Private Message System was eigentlich ursprünglich mal ganz gut funktioniert hat,
zu unskippable doppelten Werbespots und was auch immer, also es gab schon einige merkwürdige
Sachen auf YouTube, aber das deaktivieren der Dislike Anzeige ist für mich die schlechteste
Entscheidung in den letzten, keine Ahnung, sechs, sieben, acht Jahren YouTube, also das
ist echt der Wahnsinn, vor allem sie antworten ja auch noch drauf und mit was was eigentlich
überhaupt nichts aussagt ja, ich weiß das ist, ich weiß das Like Counts für die Creator
noch sichtbar sind, ja aber das bringt mir ja nix, ich bin ja nicht, ich create ja nicht
alles, ich gucke ja auch Videos, mir ging es ja darum das wenn ich Videos gucke und gerade
wenn man Tutorials sich anguckt, anguckt auf YouTube ist das wichtig, zum Beispiel, zum
Beispiel, wir nehmen mal irgendwas, keine Ahnung, suchen wir mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
wir machen mal irgendein interessantes Thema, keine Vue.js 3 oder so, Tutorial, wobei da
gibt es zu viele von, so, das suche ich danach und das erste was ich mache ist, nicht so
sehr zu gucken nach wie groß der Channel ist, sondern das erste was ich mache ist, ich filte
erstmal auf dieses Jahr, weil alles andere ist outdated as fuck, so den kenne ich, da
weiß ich, dass diese Sachen immer ganz gut sind, so aber die anderen Sachen, die würde
ich jetzt einfach, da würde ich mir jetzt einfach hier die Tabs aufmachen und dann würde
ich durchgucken, aha, sieht ganz gut aus, sieht auch ganz gut aus, vielleicht habe ich
von dem was gehört, der macht auch ganz gute Sachen, sieht auch ganz gut aus, sieht auch
ganz gut aus, der hat Weeps Sachen am Anfang, den gucke ich schon mal nicht, oder sowas
in der Richtung, zumindest, zumindest kann man das an Likes, Dislikes relativ gut erkennen
finde ich, aber, naja, ich sage euch, das wird zu Geflame führen, das wird mehr Flame-Kommentare,
ups, Flame-Kommentare geben, der Sebaro müsste erstmal wieder in Stream kommen, dass er überhaupt
irgendwelche Neues abgeben kann, der ist ja irgendwie nicht da in letzter Zeit, schon
ganz lange nicht mehr gesehen, ich mache gerade auch was Stream, ja, achso, ja, wahrscheinlich
Battlefield Zeug aufnehmen, Shryker, 5 und 9, danke für den Sub, Leute, ich scroll mal
kurz durch, Zach, Zach, ich mache, ich bin, ich, ich, ich hänge hier auf halb 8 im Stuhl,
so möglichst Rückenposition entspannt, nicht, dass ich noch mehr Kopfweh kriege, ich muss
sagen, ich, ich finde Stream so an entspannend mittlerweile, bevor ich hier sitze und ich
weiß, was ich machen soll, weil mir der Kopf wehtun, mache ich einfach Stream an, also,
zeig mal her, also ich weiß nicht, was gepappt ist, wahrscheinlich irgendwelche Drogen gespritzt
oder geraucht oder so, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht mal, was gepappt bedeutet, also,
habe ich das wahrscheinlich auch noch nicht gemacht, ja, ja, wie gesagt, Konsole ist schon
released, ich habe gehofft, vielleicht machen die wieder so einen komischen Release, dass
man gucken kann, ob es in Korea vielleicht früher kommt oder so, aber, oh, Zach, ich
habe meine Audio-Settings falsch eingestellt, sag doch was, meine Audio-Settings sacken
hier, Teams sind wieder rumgestellt, ja, so ist das viel, viel besser, excellent, ups,
viel besser so, so, ja, wie gesagt, Konsole ist schon raus und leider ist es nicht so,
dass in Korea das ganze wieder früher startet, es startet alles, glaube ich, morgen um 9
oder 10 Uhr unserer Zeit, ja, aber ich kaufe sie bestimmt nicht für die Konsole jetzt,
ja, Konsole geht schon, das weiß ich, weiß ich, aber PC nicht, sagt mal, eine Frage an
die Leute, die die letzten Call of Duty ein bisschen öfters gespielt haben, ich hatte
die Big Brain Idee letztens, aber ich glaube, da sind schon andere draufgekommen und ich
glaube, das geht nicht, aber es gibt doch Crossplay in den letzten paar Call of Duty's
und wenn man am PC mit Controller spielt, dann wird man in Xbox und Playstation Lobbies
reingeworfen, meistens Playstation Lobbies, könnte man nicht einfach mit dem Controller
Matchmaking machen und während das Match läuft, einfach auf Tastatur Maus switchen,
ich denke, das wird nicht gehen, aber gleichermaßen traue ich denen nicht zu, dass sie daran gedacht
haben, das geht nicht, hast du schon mal ausprobiert, so ein Emulator für, ja, das funktioniert
doch, es sackt, also schlechter als Tastatur, dann fliegt raus und Maus ist blockiert, aha,
ok, also haben sie da tatsächlich dran gedacht, ich bin begeistert, wie gesagt, bei mir ist
es schon da, bei mir ist es noch da, aber mal gucken, wie lange die da bleibt, Grand
Bazaar, Demoman Peak von Valdez, ja aus Battlefield 4, keine Ahnung, was für eine Map würden wir
aus Battlefield 4 nehmen, definitiv nicht die mit der Satellitenschüssel, ich meine locker
ist der Standard Pick, aber das wird dann auch langweilig, was für eine Map würde ich
aus Battlefield 4 nehmen, ich kann mich überhaupt keine gescheite Battlefield 4 Map so jetzt
erinnern, Shanghai ging mir auf den Sack, war aber noch ganz ok, das mit dem Damm war
nicht so der Wahnsinn, keine Ahnung, ah, die mit dem Hotel war ganz gut, die gingen, aber
ja Aftermath wäre nice, wäre nice, weiß ich, ob ihr schon den Portal Editor gesehen habt,
es sah ziemlich, ne, Valparaiso ist doch drin oder, Port Valdez ist nicht drinne, der Portal
Editor sah im Prinzip, also den Portal Editor, den man sich angucken konnte im Web Interface,
sah im Prinzip aus wie ein besseres Server Setting und hatte mit dem Portal, wo man irgendwie
Logikplöcke miteinander verbinden kann und so gar nichts zu tun, mal gucken, wie das ist,
ich werde mir das dann morgen mal anschauen, also wenn morgen Kopfweh besser ist, ich werde
auf jeden Fall paar Runden spielen und mal so ersten Eindruck Video machen, aber ich hatte
eigentlich vor, dann morgen Abend auch Streamstalls zu machen, Battlefield, das was ich gesehen
habe, also wer schon ein bisschen was gucken will, kann man auf YouTube gucken, der war
bei dem Capture Event und hat schon erst ein paar Sachen hochgeladen, aber was man da halt
sieht auf den Maps ist, das muss ich jetzt einfach mal sagen, die Maps sehen halt aus
wie Orbital vom Style her, also ich meine jetzt nicht, weil die ähnliche Grafik Set
verwendet, aber es sind so Battle Royale Maps irgendwie, wenn man sich das anguckt, die
Maps sind halt einfach groß, offen, mit ein paar Hotspots und dazwischen nichts und irgendwie
wirkt Battlefield einfach so, das aktuelle Battlefield, alles was ich bisher gesehen habe,
voll mit heißer Nadel gestrickt, ich meine das könnte auch Battlefield 4 sein,
aber da gucken wir morgen mal, das Game Star hat ein cooler erster Eindruck gemacht, komm
mal gucken was die Game Star sagt, Test Fazit, jetzt schon, na gut, warum nicht, warum nicht,
ich meine Hunter das ist mittlerweile echt oft genug testen, also ich glaube ehrlich
die Specialist wäre das kleinste Problem, ich glaube das was uns am meisten abfangen
wird sind die Maps, die irgendwie gar nicht für ein klassisches Battlefield so richtig
gedacht waren, muss man mal gucken, Krügel danke für den Zapp, richtig, jetzt überlegt
euch mal, wir gucken uns gleich mal das Video von Youtube an mit den Dislikes, überlegt
euch mal die ganzen Scammers, die am Start sind, oder guckt euch die Flat Earth Videos
an oder irgendwas, du siehst gar nicht mehr, was halt einfach, sag mal gut gebaitet ist
und danach zwar irgendwie zu weiter gucken einlädt, was ja das wichtigste ist für Youtube,
sonst wird es nicht empfohlen, aber eigentlich nichts mit dem Titel zu tun hat, also bei
Entertainment verstehe ich es voll und ganz, bei Entertainment geht das glaube ich auch
auf, was sich Youtube da denkt, weil Youtube hat sicherlich intern Auswertungen gemacht
und das sagen sie ja auch, dass man analysiert hat, dass Leute auch Disliked Videos viel
gucken, aber spätestens bei Technik und Tutorial Videos hört es damit halt auf, gerade wenn
es halt nur 5 Videos zum Thema gibt, wenn es was relativ spezielles ist oder nur 1, ja
das wird man nicht mehr sehen mit den Sternen, ich fand das Sternensystem eigentlich auch
ganz cool, aber das Daumen hoch Daumen runter System war auch gut, wisst ihr was ich eigentlich
ganz gut finde, wenn man, also was ich ganz cool finde ist, wenn man auf Discord die Messages
mit Emotes bewerten kann, müssen ja nicht 500 Emotes wie in Discord sein, ja dass man
das Video beispielsweise sagen kann, ist lustig, ist traurig, ist hyper, ist schlecht, wisst
ihr, dass es so 5 Emotes zur Auswahl gebe, wie man das Video bewerten kann, das fände
ich auch gut, es muss ja noch nicht mal ein Daumen runter sein, es müsste aber halt irgendwas
sein wo vom Verhältnis her klar wird, dass das Video eben qualitativ, gerade bei Technik
etwas inhaltlich nicht gut ist, seit gestern, was Windows, gucken wir uns gleich an, oh
ne nicht schon wieder, ich muss euch mal was zeigen, ich hab was lustiges auf der Arbeit
gefunden heute, also was hast du gefunden, mitbekommen, ja das ist ja bei Twitter auch
so, bei Twitter ist der chronologische Feed auch nur noch fake chronologisch, der sieht
chronologisch aus, aber im Prinzip wirst du feststellen, wenn du vielleicht auf dem
Handy mal refreshed hast und dann auf den Desktop gehst, dass manchmal Nachrichten nicht da
sind, obwohl du genau weißt, dass sie in deinem Feed waren, dann guckst du mal nach und stellst
fest, ok in deinem Feed auf Twitter taucht auch schon eine ganze Weile nicht mehr alles
auf, was man so denkt, was man eigentlich sehen müsste, wenn man die Leute followt,
leider aber Twitter ist noch am chronologischsten und eigentlich noch am ehesten so quasi dran
an so einem News Live Feed, im Vergleich zu den anderen Seiten, gut Facebook und Instagram
kann ich jetzt persönlich nichts dazu sagen, weil ich weder Facebook aktiv benutze, noch
Instagram, ja, es machen die wirklich, Battlefield 20 soll für morgen um 10 gehts los, äh um
9, 9, für alle, ich kauf mir das jetzt nicht für die Konsole extra noch, ja Reddit, Reddit
da zähl ich da jetzt mal nicht dabei, sag mal deine Meinung zu Powerline, welche der
30.000 Powerlines meinst du denn, das da was Powerline heißt, wo kann ich mein Bild doch
da essen Bild, ja also meine Meinung zu Powerline, ich habe Powerline in diesem Setup versucht
zu verwenden, wobei das ist die Wim Status Line, die Wim Status Line hab ich immer noch,
ich glaub mittlerweile hab ich die nicht mehr, aber die hab ich, oder hab ich die noch, weiß
gar nicht, ich hatte die ne ganze Weile diese Wim Status Line, die find ich cool, die find
ich nice, weil es teilweise durch die Symbole auch ein bisschen platzsparender ist, also
Wim Powerline Status Line find ich gut, ZSH Powerline find ich bloated, braucht kein Mensch,
ZSH mag ich den da, den benutze ich ZSH, ist zwar ein doppelteiliger Prompt, könnte man
jetzt auch sagen super bloated, aber ich find's deutlich geschwinter und übersichtlicher
als Powerline, also das denk ich zu Powerline, ach du meinst, achso, du meinst das Powerline
Netzwerk über Stromstecker, also über Stromleitung oder was, achso, ja ich glaube 90% der Weltbevölkerung
würden bei Powerline auch an das denken was du denkst, ich hab jetzt an was anderes
gedacht, also Powerline Strom, ganz ehrlich, ich hab damit selbst keine praktischen Erfahrungen,
ich hab kein Powerline im Einsatz, also ich würde wahrscheinlich, eh gut Kabel wird ja
nicht gehen, sonst würdest du dir da keine Gedanken zu machen, W-Lan ist gar nicht so
schlecht, gerade wenn du es so machen kannst, also wenn du wirklich nur durch die Wand fällst,
spricht ja manchmal gar nichts dagegen, dass du relativ nah hinter die Wand an Access Point
stellst und auf der anderen Seite auch noch ein, dass du das quasi einfach nur bridgest
durch die Wand, das funktioniert ja eigentlich ganz gut und ansonsten ja man kann Powerline
machen, das kann mal gut, mal schlecht funktionieren, ich hab damit keine praktischen Erfahrungen,
es gibt aber noch weitere Möglichkeiten, nämlich wenn du beispielsweise so eine ganz spezielle
Setup hast, sagen wir mal, du willst aus dem Keller ins Erdgeschoss oder sowas, dann gibt
es oftmals die Möglichkeit alte Telefonleitungen zu verwenden, also alte Kupferleitungen die
da noch liegen, die natürlich kein fertiges Netzwerkkabel sind, woraus man aber Netzwerkkabel
machen kann und es gibt mittlerweile auch Sachen, da kannst du VDSL intern machen, also ich
weiß, da ist VDSL drunter, aber das geht dann über zwei Kupferleitungen und du hast von
beiden Seiten dann Netzwerkkabel was rauskommt, hat dann zwar nur 200, 300 MBit oder so, aber
das reicht ja für die meisten Leute, die die Verbindung wollen vom Erdgeschoss zum Keller,
das geht, klar, du brauchst für Netzwerkkabel, gehen wir mal von was halbwegs modernem aus,
du brauchst für, also wir reden jetzt nicht von einer Kupferleitung und wir machen dann
irgendwie, wie heißt das, 10-Base-T oder so, ne wie hieß das, 10-Base-2, wie hieß das
mit BNC-Stecker und Collision Detect und hast du nicht gesehen, also davon reden wir jetzt
mal gar nicht, also wenn du 100 MBit brauchst, du brauchst vier Adern, vier Kupferleitungen,
aber das hat man oftmals im Keller, da ist ein Telefonanschluss oder da sind bestimmt
mal ein paar Sachen gelegt, ja, was du dazu brauchst ist ein Netzwerkstecker ohne Zange,
da kannst du es probieren, ob direkt das, direkt mit SR-Net funktioniert und ansonsten brauchst
du halt sowas, was intern VDSL macht oder irgendwas anderes für zwei Kupfer-Ader.
Ich stoppe das mit dem Physik-Grill, bei Simba, Simba hat es erledigt, ja, danke, bis denn,
tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss.
Hat das mit dem Physik-Grill doch noch funktioniert?
Ich bin bei den neuesten Mod-News nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand, wie es aussieht, zumindest
ist schon ewig durch, weiß ich doch, sage ich doch gerade, das hatte ich erledigt, bist
du krank?
Ne, klar, wobei, vielleicht habe ich mir was eingefangen, ich habe übelst Kopfweh, ja,
aber das ist ja Absicht, weil, wenn die Leute nicht mehr von sich aus suchen müssen, kannst
du ihnen quasi, kannst du sie wahrscheinlich länger auf der Plattform halten, ich denke
mal, das ist es, also für Entertainment-Zwecke funktioniert das ja auch, YouTube weiß mittlerweile,
zumindest denkt das YouTube und ich glaube, bei den meisten Leuten funktioniert das auch,
besser, was dich am Videogucken hält, ob das wirklich das ist, was du jetzt dir wünschst
oder was dich irgendwie geistig weiterbringt oder was auch immer, sei mal dahingestellt,
wahrscheinlich nicht, es orientiert sich mehr oder weniger an dem, was so am besten allgemein
verträglich ist und was man eben schön sich berieseln lassen kann, so was so der YouTube-Algorithmus
ausspuckt und das ist für YouTube natürlich toll, weil dann können sie dich den ganzen
Tag mit Videos füttern und du guckst immer ein Video an, du denkst, ja, ich kann noch
ein Video gucken und noch ein Video gucken und Viewtime ist das wichtigste für YouTube
überhaupt, das ist so wie das wichtigste für Ikea und irgendwelche Läden ist, die Leute
im Laden zu behalten, was meint ihr denn, warum die den ganzen Akt machen, bei Ikea
musst du irgendwie erstmal halbstunden Zickzackl auf und bis du durchkommst, beim Aldi wird
ab und zu mal umgeräumt, dass du wieder neu suchen musst, das machen die ja nicht, weil
sie wirklich was optimieren wollen, das ist, dass die Leute länger im Geschäft bleiben
und umso länger du im Geschäft bleibst, umso mehr kaufst du, ganz einfach, was ist denn
hier los, jetzt müssen wir gleich mal gucken, chat habt ihr euch eingehackt, gibts zu,
warum, warum, ich muss mal gucken, was ist hier aktiv im Hintergrund, was ist hier aktiv
im Hintergrund, Hacker-Mans sind am Start, ich sehe es schon hier, guck mal, was ist
hier, OBS, Web-Application 11, OMG, die Web-Application 11 ist da, das ist nicht Standard, das müssen
die Hacker-Mans aus Indien sein, von Microsoft Support, oh ich muss morgen vor Battlefield
unbedingt noch mal ein Grafikkarten 3x aktualisieren fällt mir gerade ein, naja, wie gesagt, oh
was hat er denn geschrieben, was hat er denn Schlimmes gemacht, ah, er hat ein Timeout
eingelöst, ok, Moin Bambusbjorn, hast du dich schon vor LevelCaptchie Bane lassen,
er hat ein kurzes Review zu Battlefield gemacht, können wir mal gucken, gucken wir mal LevelCaptchie,
ich kann euch jetzt sagen, was witzig ist, wenn ich die ganzen Promotion Videos sehe,
weiß ich jetzt noch bis Paid Promotion Videos oder nicht, weil ich das Briefing gelesen
habe zu den Videos, da kenne ich gleich, wer auch Sellout Videos macht, das wäre nicht,
ist Popo S gut, ich habe Popo S im Streamer ausprobiert und war nicht so wahnsinnig begeistert,
ich weiß aber nicht mehr warum, kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern, die Musiklautstärke
ok, ich habe auch ein bisschen lauter gemacht, weil ich das äußerst entspannend finde,
frag mal Linus Tech Tips zu Popo S, warum, wird er gesponsert von denen, finde das jetzt
gut oder, Zavod, ja das war eine gute Map, Zavod war gut, ich weiß das heißt auf Russisch
Fabrik, ich kann nur brüviert unser Wort, mehr kann ich nicht auf Russisch, Gekommnet
kann ich noch, ich glaube das ist kein richtiges Russisch Gekommnet, mehr kann ich nicht Russisch,
gibt es da lustige Geschichten zu, wir hatten mal auf der Arbeit drei Russen und die haben
immer, 1-2 mal am Tag zumindest hat sich das für uns so angehört, ich weiß nicht auf
was für ein russisches Wort die wirklich gesagt haben, aber sie haben es uns danach
mal erklärt, zumindest die haben immer so 2-3 mal am Tag haben die gesagt Kackbude,
zumindest hat sich das für uns angehört wie Kackbude und ich habe mir gedacht die
meinen halt den Laden wo sie hier sind, aber die reden Russisch was ist das und irgendwann
hat mir das mal einer unserer Russen erklärt, ich weiß nicht wie das Wort korrekt heißt,
aber das was sich für mich angehört hat wie Kackbude heißt wie gehts dir, auf Russisch,
wie gehts dir Russisch, ja jetzt geht in die Richtung, ja ok fast fast, irgendwie sowas
in der Richtung zumindest war ich hart irritiert weil die irgendwie 2-3 mal am Tag Kackbude
gesagt haben, zumindest irgendwie sowas in der Richtung das heißt wie gehts dir auf
Russisch, ach guck mal ich hab im Stream ja Kopf weg geschrieben, nicht Kopf weh, Kopf
weg Entspannungsstream, siehst du mal, ich mein den Titel kann er richtig schreiben,
Kopf weg Entspannungsstream, Kopf ab, ja, guck mal die Baguettes konnten das gut, die
einer gerade den Franzosen Pepe postet, die konnten das, so 1700 irgendwas oder so, das
hatten die richtig drauf, ja GameStar können wir uns gleich angucken, ja da hatte ich den
sich grad schon aufgemacht GameStar, warte mal ich muss mal das alte Zeug zumachen, ich
blick hier überhaupt nicht mehr durch, ja, G-Bay den Level Cap, Streamsteller ist immer
gern, Poggers, ja gucken wir uns gleich an, also ich persönlich würde jemand der wirklich
neu mit Linux anfängt, warum ist ByteStrike kein WIP, weil ByteStrike einmal irgendwas
geschrieben, ich weiß gar nicht was es war, einmal irgendwas geschrieben hat was echt
praktisch war, aber ansonsten eher am Trollen ist die ganze Zeit, so kriegt man kein WIP,
Packweight, also was ich empfehlen würde wenn man neu mit Linux einsteigt und sich einfach
nur ein bisschen rantasten will ist entweder Ubuntu, wobei ich Ubuntu auf dem Desktop überhaupt
nicht mag oder Mint, damit es ist Ubuntu basiert oder ne Debian mittlerweile glaube ich, glaubt
ich, haben die nicht die Ubuntu Base weggeschmissen, ach keine Ahnung, das finde ich zum Einstieg
echt ganz gut und es hat auch eine riesen Userbasis mit, finde ich, recht hilfsbereiten
Leuten, ja, so, das ist gut, das kann man sich nämlich auch wunderbar in der VM installieren
und das ist das nächste was ich empfehlen würde, wenn man anfängt nicht irgendwo auf
der Hardware installieren, macht eine VM, kostet ja nichts, muss ja nicht unbedingt
eine Forever Workstation Pro sein, sondern das reicht, alles mögliche was man virtualisieren
kann, dann macht euch eine Linux VM und legt euch das wie ich auf den zweiten Desktop
und bastelt damit rum, Dualboot mit zwei getrennten SSDs, nee, ich würde ehrlich gesagt mit einer
VM anfangen, das ist das Einfachste, da hast du auch dein Windows am Start, wo du rüber
switchen kannst und gucken kannst, warum ist denn das so klein, oh, was ist das für
Cokomodate Hintergrund heute, Massive Cokomodates, das ist das Big Image of the Day, ist heute
irgendwas Ami-mäßiges oder ist das Kokona Hintergrund, ich weiß es gar nicht, ist heute
irgendwas bei den Amis oder so, heute ist St.
Martin, ja aber ich glaube nicht, dass St. Martin irgendwas mit Marine-Leuten zu tun
hat, USA Feiertage 2021, was ist denn heute, Ernte Dankfest, nee, Tag der Veteranen ist
heute, ja deswegen, Tag der Veteranen ist heute, deswegen sind da die Segler im Hintergrund,
jetzt habe ich es verstanden, alles klar, übrigens, was mich auch überrascht hat,
dass die Amis sehr unkreativ sind beim benennen ihrer Feiertage, ich meine, die haben am 25.11.
haben sie hier Thanksgiving, wisst ihr, wie zumindest laut dem Apple-Kalender, der Tag
nach Thanksgiving heißt, der ist nämlich auch ein Feiertag, der heißt legit Day after Thanksgiving,
also busy kreativer könnte man doch wirklich sein für die Feiertage, ich meine, erster
und zweiter Weihnachtsfeiertag ist jetzt auch nicht wirklich hochkranisch, also irgendwie
hochkranisch innovativ oder so, aber ein bisschen besser kann man es da machen, ich
meine, guck mal, die hätten noch irgendeinen heiligen gefunden oder so, dem sie den Tag
hätten widmen können, was weiß ich, der heilige Chat, keine Ahnung, ob es den gibt, gibt es
einen Chat, den gibt es ja wirklich, das hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht, der heilige Chat,
den gibt es ja ernsthaft, alles klar, gut zu wissen, heute lernt man wieder was, alles
klar, der Chat von Jörg, ok, ahja, das ist ja schon ein bisschen her, 664 bis 669, und
was hat da für Wunder gewirkt, Wunder, wie, keine, man muss doch um heilig gesprochen
zu werden doch, ah nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, muss man nicht, das war bestimmt ein Märtyrer,
es gibt nämlich, habe ich nämlich mal in einer Doku gesehen, es gibt zwei Wege, wie du heilig
gesprochen werden kannst in der katholischen Kirche, du musst entweder Märtyrer sein,
das ist relativ easy, ja, du musst halt für deinen Glauben dich umbringen lassen oder
so, das ist dann relativ einfach oder du musst nachweislich, das ist ja der Witz, wie man
das nachweislich, du musst nachweislich zwei Wunder gewirkt haben, was ist einfacher,
das ist einfacher Chat, jetzt wisst ihr auch warum es fast nur Märtyrer heilige gibt,
weil Wunder wirken halt irgendwie schwierig ist ja, vor allem nachweislich, ich meine,
das ganze Ding, also diese komplette Sache hat nichts mit Nachweisen zu tun, warum müssen
die Wunder nachgewiesen werden, na gut, ich meine, das ist einfach, ich glaube, ich glaube
beim letzten Papst haben sie doch auch irgendwo im hintersten Polen irgendwo eine gefunden,
diese, die ja spontan geheilt hat, Instant Heal und das war dann ausreichend, das ist
alles ein Schwachsinn, meine Güte, es ist immer, das ist richtig pepega, also so Glaubenssachen
sind echt hardcore pepega, ja, aber andere Glaubenssachen, es gab wieder ein Shitstorm
auf Twitter, weil, ob ich das jetzt richtig zusammenkriege, in Vanguard im Zombie Modus
lag irgendwo ein Koran rum und da geht es natürlich dann ab im Zombie Modus und das
ist ja ganz furchtbar unheilig und da wurde Shitstormt auf Twitter wieder des Todes, ja,
die Leute haben alle Probleme, ey, also ganz im Ernst, Gläubige aller Glaubensrichtung,
die sollen einfach mal ihr Zeug auf die Reihe kriegen, ja, wenn die alle so überzeugt
von Sinn, dann sollten sie doch nicht gleich irgendwie an allem zweifeln, nur weil in
dem Game irgendwas drin ist, die haben echt, die sind alle nicht mehr ganz dicht, allesamt,
ich mach da überhaupt keine Ausnahme, die haben alle einen Dachschaden, wie auch immer
der imaginäre Freund im Himmel heißt, die haben alle einen Dachschaden, nein, man kann
jeder glauben, was er will, meinetwegen, aber trotzdem Dachschaden, ich glaub an den Chat,
der Chat weiß immer, was man machen muss, wenn eine Ahnung hat, dann der Chat und ich
könnte mir vorstellen, dass, ähm, Sekunde, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass der Chat sogar,
wenn man da mal eine Statistik machen würde, deutlich öfters richtig liegt im, sag mal
irgendwie Zukunft voraussagen oder sonst was, als irgendwelche heiligen Schriften, die es
so gibt auf der Welt, weil es ist ja erwiesen, oder weiß ich, ob das erwiesen ist, aber
ich bilde mir ein, als ich da was drüber gelesen hab, dass Kollektiv an Leuten bessere
und weißere Entscheidungen treffen, oder sagen wir mal nachhalt, nee, nicht nachhaltiger,
also, also quasi bessere Entscheidungen als einzelne und ich könnte mir fast vorstellen,
dass der Chat so als Kollektiv da öfters richtig liegt, das will ich jetzt aber nicht
ausprobieren, weil dann müsste man das mit irgendwas ausprobieren und ich will den Chat
nicht Aktien kaufen lassen vor meinem Geld oder so, das muss, also so weit müssen wir
es jetzt ja nicht treiben und wisst ihr eigentlich, was ich besonders witzig an diesem, an diesem
Religions und, und, äh, was, was ich den größten imaginären Freund finde, die, wo
man besonders drüber lacht, nämlich zum Beispiel sind es, sind es die Zeugen Jehovas,
wo angeblich die, die, die Aliens mit dem Raumschiff kommen, ich glaube es sind die
Zeugen Jehovas, also sprich, die, die, über die man am größten lacht, die haben eigentlich
noch den, ich mein, es ist auch nicht wirklich, ist es Scientology, ich weiß es nicht, ist
scheißegal, irgendeine Glaubensgemeinschaft, also die, wo man sagt, das ist ja der abgedrehteste
Shit aller Zeiten, ist rein logisch und sag mal wissenschaftlich betrachtet noch das Wahrscheinlichste,
wenn auch extrem unwahrscheinlich, aber wenn du das mal vergleichst, dass irgendwann mal
hier Aliens vorbeikommen und Leute mit dem Raumschiff abholen, ist theoretisch zumindest
kein Ding der Unmöglichkeit, wohingegen das, was in der Bibel und im Koran steht, doch
irgendwie sehr, sehr, also noch deutlich unwahrscheinlicher ist, ja, also das ist grad der Witz, dass die,
die am abgedrehtesten sind, eigentlich noch am nächsten an der Realität dran sind, Spalter,
oh man, so, weiter gehts, widmen wir uns wieder mit normalen Themen, wir sind euch von Specialists
überzeugt, ja, ich auch nicht, aber wie gesagt, Maps wären das größte Problem, glaube ich,
so, wollen wir uns mal das GameStar Video angucken, ich mach jetzt erstmal den Chat, den Chat durch,
Max glaubt an den Markt, wir wissen, dass der Markt das regelt, der Lindner hat uns
erzählt, der Markt regelt das, also regelt das der Markt auch, es wäre das erste Mal,
dass irgendjemand, den wir gewählt haben, erzählt, was nicht, also was erzählt, was
nicht stimmen würde, das kommt nicht vor und wenn der Lindner sagt, der Markt regelt das,
dann muss der Markt das regeln, wir wurden noch, uns wurde da noch nie Mist erzählt,
kann nicht sein, ja, wie gesagt, ich würde auch lieber mit Ubuntu anfangen oder mit
Metro, Metro gibt es ja, was ist denn hier eigentlich los, löscht ihr euch denn gegenseitig,
ja, minze ich auch, so, die sollen alle machen, was sie wollen, ich persönlich, ihr wisst,
ich hab's mit Religion auch überhaupt nicht, aber ich folge trotzdem dem Dalai Lama auf Twitter,
so bisschen tägliche Erleuchtung ist ja nicht schlecht, allerdings muss ich sagen,
ich bin auch noch nicht mal mit dem Dalai Lama jedes Mal einer Meinung, zu 99% finde ich das
äußerst tiefsinnig und sinnvoll, was er schreibt, aber letztens hat er was geschrieben, so nach dem
Motto, alle Menschen wollen doch nur in Frieden leben und da denke ich mir so, ja, ok, auf 99%
der Menschen trifft das zu, aber es gibt genug Gestörte, die das eben nicht wollen,
das ist ja das Problem an der Sache, dass es immer ein paar Gestörte gibt, die kein Bock auf sowas
haben, seit gestern, ja, das gucken wir uns gleich an, morgen online Gespräch für Ausbildung,
Poggers, easy win, das kriegst du, du musst einfach sagen, du guckst regelmäßig Wubblers
auf Twitch und easy job und wenn du da noch Prime-Sub hast, was meinst du, wie schnell die
den Ausbildungsvertrag auf dem Tisch klatschen, aber ich sehe, du bist kein Prime-Sub,
ach doch, du bist, nee, du bist kein Prime-Sub, nee, dann geht das nicht, dann dauert es bisschen,
aber vielleicht reicht schon, wenn du sagst, du guckst ab und zu Wubblers,
hey, meinst du, es lohnt sich auch als Web-Dev mit einem Auto, ja natürlich,
also man muss sagen, natürlich ist das immer nur meiner Meinung nach, wisst ihr,
man muss ja nicht immer dabei sagen, aber wie gesagt, ich sehe es halt so,
dass die eigentliche Zukunft schon Richtung Full-Stack geht oder eigentlich schon ist.
Und das heißt auch im Endeffekt, dass du als Frontend-Dev dich mit Backends-Sachen
und Server-Sachen auskennen solltest und umgedreht. Das heißt nicht,
dass du da übelst tiefgehenden Plan haben musst, aber ich denke mal,
zu wissen, wie man eine Web-Anwendung baut, also wie man eine Web-Anwendung entwickelt,
schrägstich programmiert, baut, deploit und laufen lässt auf irgendeiner wie geartene
Infrastruktur auch immer, ist wichtig, gerade in Clouds-Zeiten. Ich glaube,
in der heutigen Zeit ist es einfach nicht mehr so klar mit der Trennung und man sieht es ja auch,
dass gerade jetzt auch bei Ausbildung, was Fachinformatik, Anwendungsentwicklung,
Systemintegration angeht und sowas, das mag zwar in der Ausbildung noch ein bisschen getrennt sein,
ist es auch nicht wirklich großartig, aber danach verschwimmt das, verschwimmt das immer weiter.
Ich meine, ich bin noch das beste Beispiel für, guck mal, ich habe mal irgendwann bei
einem Provider fachinformatiker Systemintegration gelernt und mit täglichem Rechenzentrum rumgerannt.
Heute mache ich irgendwelche Git-Repos und Programmierstellen und Cloud-Automatisierung
Sachen. Das hat mit dem, was ich ursprünglich da in der Richtung, was ich da gelernt und gemacht
habe, eigentlich gar nichts mehr zu tun. Also ich glaube, die Zukunft ist full stack und wird es
auch bleiben. Natürlich kann man, also muss man ja auch in Fokus haben, das ist ja gar nicht die
Frage. Full stack heißt ja nicht, auch wenn das in den Stellenanzeigen oftmals so drinsteht,
dass du quasi 5x beliebige Leute, wo full stack dransteht, nehmen kannst und die können dann
alles perfekt. Das ist ja nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sache. Aber dass man sagt, hey, ich bin rein
Java-Backend oder ich bin rein, was weiß ich, JavaScript-Frontend oder ich bin rein irgendwie
Cobalt auf dem Host oder so. Gut, das war jetzt ein doofes Beispiel, das gibt es immer noch. Das
ist glaube ich nicht mehr so das Ding. Ja, also um es kurz zu machen, ich denke schon, dass das
sinnvoll ist, sich damit vertraut zu machen. Ne, Gnome mag ich auch nicht. Die 3WM ist beste. Ja,
genau, sehe ich dich auch so. Gleich schauen wir uns mit dem Chat, dann gucken wir mal das
GameStar-Video. Obwohl, ich wollte euch noch was anderes lustiges zeigen. Habt ihr es mitbekommen,
dass NPM mal wieder gehackerment wurde? Oder es stimmt nicht, endlich NPM. Zwei größere Packages
auf NPM wurden vor ein paar Tagen wieder gehackerment. Ja, NPM, Core und LC. New NPM library
hijacks, Core und LC. Ja, das eine ist ein Command-Line-Parser und das andere habe ich
vergessen, was es ist. Was aber ganz lustig ist, es ist anscheinend Windows-Only. Mal gucken, ob
ich den GitHub-Thread finde. Ja, hier, das da. Es ist Windows-Only, so wie es aussieht und wenn
man dieses Package in der falschen Version installiert hat, NPM, dann hat man sich Malware
eingefangen unter Windows. Und die Hackermans waren sogar so faul und haben den IF eingebaut,
ich hoffe, ich finde das jetzt. Haben den IF eingebaut, ja, oder auch nicht. Hier, haben
den IF eingebaut, dass es auch nur auf Windows passiert. Guck mal, IF Win32 oder Win64, dann
macht CMD auf und führt Compile-Buds aus. Das ist übrigens ein Kritikpunkt, den es schon sehr
lange an NPM gibt, dass NPM so Pre-Install-Hooks hat, die eben Binary-Sachen dann auch compilen
können und so, was die meisten Packages gar nicht brauchen. Das heißt, das Beste, was man
machen kann, ist eigentlich NPM diese Install-Scripts ausschalten, dass das nicht mehr ausgeführt wird.
Ja, also wenn man diese zwei, wenn man wie gesagt Core oder RC installiert hat, in den
letzten zwei Wochen hat man sich, unter Windows, hat man sich wahrscheinlich ein Keylogger und
Passwort-Klau-Trojaner-Kram eingefangen. Das ist ziemlich dumm. Und jetzt kommt die
Geschichte dabei, das ist uns auf der Arbeit aufgefallen und wir haben sicherlich Entwickler
mit Windows-Notebooks, die sich den Kram installiert haben. 100 pro. Also wir haben relativ viele
Frontend-Leute, die Zeug machen, weil wir haben ja glaube ich über 180 Webseiten oder so. Ist jetzt
kein Witz, wir haben ernsthaft über 180 Webseiten. Da ist zwar kaum was drauf los, aber wir haben
über 180 Webseiten. Und wenn nicht sogar über 200 mittlerweile. Und da ist relativ viel Frontend-Stells
am Start und garantiert haben das Leute gemacht. 100 pro. Naja, zumindest kam dann jemand zu uns und hat
gesagt, hier guckt mal auf euren Linux-Servern, ob die Pakete da drauf sind. Da habe ich mir so gedacht,
ja okay, da hat er ja schon recht, aber wie soll ich ihn das rauskriegen? Die ganzen Frontend-Dinger
bringen ihre eigenen Note-Modules mit. So und was machen wir jetzt? Wir machen jetzt einen Find über
5000 Linux-Systeme. Das läuft ein bisschen. Ich habe das angeschmissen und es läuft heute Nacht.
Mal gucken. Ich habe das auf meinem Notebook heute Mittag angeschmissen. Mal gucken, das wird
wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern. So, Find über 5000 Linux-Kisten, wo Note-Modules
rumliegen und dann gucken, ob da Core oder LC drinne ist. NPM-QAMEN? Naja, das bringt ja nix.
Wenn NPM installiert ist, ist es gar kein Problem. Note-Modules sind ja das Problem. Note-Modules und
dass dort vor Ort, dass dann irgendwer ausgeführt hat, vielleicht auf den Server gegangen ist und
dort seine Web-Anwendung gebaut hat. Das ist ja das Problem. Das kann ja jeder mit einem Login
auf dem Linux-System gewesen sein. Ob es am Endeffekt funktioniert, keine Ahnung. Es ist so,
wie es aussieht, den 99 prozent Windows betroffen, aber 100 prozent ausschließen,
dass da auf die Lungsbox ist, kann ich nicht. Mit welchen Tools startest du das auf so vielen
Kisten? Der Vorschleife und SSH. Läuft auf meinem Notebook gerade. Ja, genau so was. Wie gesagt,
ich habe nur Kopfweh. Aber es wird besser, ohne Scheiß. Ich finde Stream-Stells mittlerweile so
entspannend. Ich lege jetzt hier auf halb acht vorm Rechner, gucke ein bisschen Chat,
labere ein bisschen. Ich habe jetzt weniger Kopfweh als am Anfang. Loki, Tom, danke für den Sub.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Bist du an der Börse investiert? Sehr gute Frage. Sehr gute Frage.
Das ist ein Thema, mit dem ich mich dringendst beschäftigen muss. Sei es nur, dass ich mir
irgendwie ETFs kaufe oder so, wo man nicht viel denken muss, weil wir haben jetzt ja 4,5 Prozent
Inflationsrate. Habe ich auch letztens auf Twitter geschrieben. Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung,
was so Finanzstells angeht. Aber wir haben 4,5 Prozent Inflationsrate. Ja, und ich weiß,
das meiste ist, glaube ich, Strom und wie heißt das? Treibstoff und sowas. Aber wenn man sich
überlegt, das ist mehr, als wir sonst in einem Jahr haben. Wir können im Stream gemeinsam was
einkaufen. Oh ja, ich glaube, das ist das Allerbeste. Das ist dann quasi fast so wie
Slot. In einem Monat. Das ist fast so wie Slotmaschinen, wenn der Chat mein Geld in
Aktien investieren darf. Das kann ja nur gut werden. Das müsste man echt machen. Ich müsste
mal 70,30. Was heißt 70,30 in dem Fall? Das müsste man echt mal machen. Ich müsste mal so
wie 200 Euro nehmen und dann müsste man echt machen. Twitch Chat kauft Aktien. 70 Low Risk,
30 Spekulation. Das heißt, 30 Prozent kaufe ich dann Litecoin oder was? Alles auf AMD.
Oh, excellent, excellent. Geh bloß nicht bei den China-Chinesen rein. Nee, keine Sorge,
ich gehe nicht bei den China-Chinesen rein. So. Was? Er hat Steam installiert und durch
ein Bug im Package Manager seinen Desktop gelöscht. Das ist Popo erst. Ja, ich wusste,
warum ich das nicht mag. Man streamt so morgen. Also wenn ich morgen weniger Kopfweh habe,
dann stream ich morgen. Über welche Plattform investierst du ihr? Ich hier gar nicht. Das
ist mein Problem. Und wenn das weitergeht, dann ist mein Geld ja bald weg. So wie Kopfweg
heute. Ist das Geld dann weg? Oh stimmt, es ist ja 11.11. Da kommt ja wenn die Leute ja
wieder witzig. Das habe ich ganz, ganz vergessen. Ist ja wieder so weit. Alvirtuose, danke für
den Sub und sorry an alle, die ich nicht gesehen habe und irgendwas übersehen habe hier. Tut
mir leid. Danke für die ganzen Subs. Das habe ich ja ganz vergessen. Das ist ja auch
wieder am Start. Ich frage mich, wie die das dieses Jahr machen. So wegen Corona und so.
Oster, Sonntag, Montag auch sehr kreativ. Ja, immer noch besser als Day after Thanksgiving.
Aber heute haben wir schon mal gelernt, es gibt einen heiligen Chat. Wusste ich auch
noch nicht. Schon gesehen, irgendwelche Items wurden schon in Battlefield deaktiviert. Nein,
habe ich nicht gesehen. Wenn ich morgen sehen. Gifters anscheinend nicht. Wie kann man sich
selbst eigentlich am besten Programmieren beitragen? Habe irgendwelche keine Ideen,
was gut für Anfang wäre. Die Sache ist die am besten ist das eigentlich, wenn man irgendwie
eine Vorstellung hat, was man gerne machen möchte und sich dann eben das passende raussucht
und damit anfängt. Ja, wenn du jetzt sagst, ich würde gerne eine Webseite machen, klar,
dann liegt es auf der Hand, hat dem jetzt JavaScript. Wenn du sagst, hey, ich würde
gern irgendwie den super Next Gen Windows Desktop Taschenrechner programmieren, dann
müsste man sich vielleicht was auf der Basis mit eventuell UVP überlegen. Wobei UVP ist
halt was auch immer. Ja, wenn es irgendwelche Arduino Geschichten sein soll, dann kommt man
an C++ nicht vorbei. Also es ist immer ganz interessant, wenn man weiß, in welche Richtung
die Interessen liegen. Also was interessiert dich denn? Also es muss ja den Grund haben,
warum du anfangen willst. Also welche Bereiche sind denn die, die dich interessieren? Wenn
es Richtung Machine Learning oder vielleicht irgendwelche Bot Geschichten geht, ist natürlich
heißen wunderbar, wenn es irgendwelche. Ja, für was kann man eigentlich Go bei einem Einsteiger
empfehlen? Ich weiß, dass Go eine megabeliebte Einsteiger-Programmiersprache ist, aber was
ist so das Thema, wo ich einem Einsteiger wirklich Go empfehlen würde? Außer dass es
eben viele Tutorials gibt und viele Ressourcen und Material und die Sprache eigentlich relativ
simpel zumindest am Anfang ist. Cloud, ja, aber keiner macht mit Cloud Sachen. Da habe
ich auch zuerst dran gedacht, aber keiner fängt mit Cloud Sachen an zu programmieren. CLI
Tools, ja, tatsächlich, ja. Ja, Command- und Seilen-Tools, aber ich glaube, damit fängt
auch kaum einer an. Du kannst ja mal schreiben im Chat, was dich interessiert. Aber schreib
mir ein Wupplos davor, dass ich gleich sehe, wenn ich dann irgendwann mal im Chat fertig
bin. Was verdienst du noch mal grob in deinem Job? War ja tarifgebunden, damit eh öffentlich.
Ja, ja, der Teil, der tarifgebunden ist, war öffentlich. Du kannst dir einfach das Video
angucken. Irgendwo hier erzähle ich, warte mal. Ja, Max, redet nicht so viel im heißen
Treibraum. Ach so, jetzt hier erzähle ich. So, jetzt, Achtung. Alter Max, kommt zu Punkt.
Genau. Und als allererstes gucken wir uns mal den Tarifvertrag an. Er sagt es einfach
nicht. Er sagt es einfach nicht. Selbstgebildet. Max, mach's. Mach's.
Ja, hier. Okay, also, das ist der Tarifvertrag. Ich bin, glaube, hier gerade. Ich sag's im
Video auch noch, wo ich bin, aber ich glaube, ich bin hier. Ja. Aber wie gesagt, da kommt
noch ein bisschen was dabei. Ja, bei uns ist es auch mal 14. Auf, Max, komm, Spucks, aus.
Gib's uns. Ja, Moment, das ist der Tarifvertrag. Alter, habe ich da wirklich 14 Minuten drüber
gelabert und 5 Sekunden gesagt, was ich eigentlich verdiene? Bist du nachher um 0 Uhr bei Battlefield
am Start? Um 0 Uhr ist es gar nicht gestartet. Startet morgen um 9 Uhr. Ja, ich streame morgen.
Das ist jetzt allerdings vertragsabhängig, also das das Ganze regelt. Und darauf, je nachdem,
wie das Geschäftsjahr so lief. Jetzt auf, sag's. Sag's, Max, sag's. Sag's. Das ist jetzt vertragsmäßig,
aber weiß ich nicht, ob ich das sagen darf, wie das ist. Und so, wenn man das nimmt und
das alles zusammenrechnet. Hab ich's bald. Bei manchen Stellen rundet man mal ein bisschen
auf und dann rundet man noch ein bisschen ab. Ja, ja, ja. Dann verdiene ich, auf 5 Tage
wohlgemerkt, ungefähr, klat, 70.000 Euro im Jahr. Ja, wunderbar, wir haben es geschafft.
70k. In 5 Tagen. Wohlgemerkt. In 4 Tagen ist das dann mal 0,8 in die 56k. Fast wie im Modem.
Also 4 Tage 56.000 Euro im Jahr. Genau. Und das ist gar nicht besonders viel, muss man
sagen, wenn man in Frankfurt ist und ein bisschen rumguckt. Aber ich hab da echt keine Schmerzen
und ich bin ganz gerne da, wo ich bin. Der Stress hält sich in Grenzen und ich sehe
keinen Grund, irgendwie meinen Job zu wechseln. Zumal ich halt den großen Vorteil hab, dass
ich noch Twitch und YouTube und stealth nebenbei machen kann und deswegen doppelt verdiene.
Ich bin da wirklich äußerst entspannt, was finanzielle Sachen angeht, zumal ich auch
niemand bin, der viel Geld ausgibt. Ich geb wirklich wenig Geld aus. Und gar nicht
mal, weil ich mir nix leisten will, sondern weil ich eigentlich, das meiste ist mir eigentlich
egal. Wenn ich mir dann mal was kaufen will, dann kauf ich's mir halt auch, weil ist ja
dann genug Kohle da. Aber ich fahr weder irgendwie ultra luxuriös in Urlaub, noch hab ich irgendwie
das mega fette Auto am Start, noch bräuchte ich irgendwie, keine Ahnung, was man da urinne
oder so. Dafür hab ich das agilste Auto. Auch mein Auto hat Probleme, das quietscht
seit zwei Tagen. Das quietscht beim losfahren. Vielleicht muss ich mir doch bald ein neues
Auto kaufen. Investiert an Geld und geh früher in Ruhe, stand ich... also ich muss jetzt
überlegen, wie ich das sage, weil ich will jetzt nicht die Leute ärgern. Das mag jetzt
vielleicht bisschen pepega klingen, aber ich will niemand damit schibaten oder irgendwie
sagen, dass ich da viel besser bin oder so. Aber ich hab nicht vor, bis zum Rentenalter
zu arbeiten. Wirklich nicht. Was ist denn das mittlerweile? 67? Wahrscheinlich, wenn
ich in Rente gehe 70 oder so. Ich hab nicht vor zu arbeiten bis 67. Ich mach lieber früher
Schluss mit Arbeiten und mach dann mehr das worauf ich Bock hab. Sei es irgendwelche privaten
Projekte, sei es vielleicht dann immer noch YouTube streamen oder sonst was. Dann bin
ich nicht nur Boomer wie jetzt, sondern bin ich richtig echter Boomer. Wieso nicht? Ja,
Moment. Das heißt ja nicht, dass ich nicht mehr dann irgendwie Sachen mache, auf die
ich Bock hab. Das kann ja schon sowas sein in der Richtung, wie das was ich jetzt mache.
Ja, es kann sein, dass ich irgendwelche Sachen dann vielleicht noch programmiere oder vielleicht
hab ich. Hey, ich mein, man steckt ja da nicht drinnen. Das war jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
doof Überleitung, aber man steckt ja da nicht drinnen. Vielleicht hab ich vielleicht tatsächlich
Familie und Kinder bis dahin. Man weiß es ja nicht. Kann ja alles sein. Und keine Ahnung,
was dann ist. Aber ich hab nicht vor, bis 67 zu arbeiten. Ja, so hätten wir das auch
geklärt. Plan deine Bank eine Migration Richtung Cloud. Wir sind schon mit sehr vielen Sachen
in der Cloud. Wir sind schon mit sehr vielen Sachen in der Cloud. Wir rechnen uns und reden
das uns zwar immer noch ein bisschen schön, dass wir angeblich mit noch mehr Sachen in
der Cloud sind, wie wir eigentlich schon sind. Einfach weil es cooler aussieht, prozentual
in irgendwelchen Crafts oder so. Aber wir sind schon mit erstaunlich vielen Sachen in
der Cloud. Und das birgt so seine Probleme. Also Cloud ist ja nicht instant sorgenlos.
Zum Beispiel hat man dann Probleme, wo man nie damit rechnen würde, dass man Probleme
hat. Wenn du lokal was hast mit vielen kleinen Dateien, dann ist das relativ schnell, weil
da ist halt ein SSD drin oder ein Storage angebunden oder schnelle SAS Festplatten, was auch immer.
Viele kleine Dateien lokal sind nicht das große Problem. Macht mal viele kleine Dateien
über Azure, NFS. Das könnt ihr komplett vergessen. Da ist ein 56k Modem dagegen schnell.
Weiß nicht, ob jemand schon von euch die Ehre hatte, mal über Azure Files, NFS viele
kleine Dateien machen zu dürfen. Das ist nicht machbar. PowerShell 5 wusste gar nicht,
dass wir da bei Version 5 mittlerweile sind. Jede Filiale hat eine eigene Seite. Ja, ja,
ja, jede Filiale. Also das, aber das zählt nicht. Das meine ich nicht. Damit das läuft
alles auf dem gleichen Service natürlich. Ne, wir haben total viele. Ich weiß auch nicht,
warum wir so viele Seiten haben, aber wir haben so viele Seiten. Da sind die unterschiedlichsten
Sachen dabei. Von Wohltätigkeitssachen bis zu Stonks Zeug. Mein Freund hat heute Vorstellungsgespräch
bei der Firma und fand das richtig toll. Ah, nice. Übrigens, ich habe mal bei uns nachgefragt,
wie haben leider kein Mitarbeiter empfehlen Mitarbeiter so weit übergreifend, als dass
ich ihn empfehlen könnte und dann Stonks bekomme. Leider nicht. Das wäre es jetzt. Ja. So dicke
sind wir mit denen anscheinend doch nicht. Es wäre geil gewesen. Es wäre geil gewesen.
Dann hätte ich irgendjemand empfohlen, den ich gar nicht kenne. Aber Stonks. Mit welchem
wie gesagt, Vorschleife SSH easy. Doch, klar, natürlich. Da hätte man vieles besser machen
können und sei es nur irgendwie ein Playbook, was das für dich ausführt oder so. Aber
so eine Vorschleife mit SSH, wenn du eine Hostliste hast, die hatte ich ja. Wenn du
eine TXT-Natei mit allen Hosts hast, so ein SSH mit Vorschleife machst du halt in zwei
Minuten. Alles andere dauert ein bisschen länger. Terox, danke für den Sub. Das dauert,
aber das läuft heute halt über Nacht. Meinetwegen. Und morgen ist wahrscheinlich immer noch
nicht fertig. Das muss auf jeden Fall nächste Woche, 19. fertig sein, weil dann gehe ich
in den Urlaub. Wie gesagt, über einen Monat jetzt. Aber zum größten Teil kommt das ja
von Energiepreisen und Öl und so was, wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe. Also es ist jetzt
nicht so, dass keine Ahnung, im Supermarkt die Sachen jetzt in einem Monat 4,5% teurer
geworden sind. Aber insgesamt ist es schon teurer geworden. Was natürlich ein bisschen
doof ist, weil das gerade wieder auch die Leute trifft, die eh schon wenig Geld haben.
Da gibt es unglaublich viele Leute, das wundert mich auch immer. Es gibt so viele Leute, die
von Monat zu Monat leben, also quasi von Null auf dem Konto zu Null auf dem Konto. Wisst
ihr, wie ich meine, der hat eine Null auf dem Konto, dann kriegt der Gehalt, gibt die
Sachen aus, am Ende ist wieder eine Null drauf. Also quasi von, wie sagt man, vom Gehalt
in den Mund. Nee, wie sagt man da? Naja, zumindest es gibt unglaublich viele Leute,
das überrascht mich auch immer wieder, die einfach quasi arbeiten gehen, nur um zu, wie
soll man sagen, nur um zu überleben, ohne davon was machen zu können. Das muss man
sich auch mal immer wieder vergegenwärtigen, wie oft es das gibt, dass es da einem eigentlich
relativ gut geht. Ja, paycheck to paycheck, genau, das meine ich. Also ich weiß, das bei
uns auf der Arbeit, wir haben auch welche. Gut, ich meine, die haben noch ein bisschen
mehr, die haben noch ein bisschen mehr Ausgaben, von dem einen weiß ich, der hat ja noch Frau
und Kinder und so, aber trotzdem, der hat immer quasi immer Null auf dem Konto, der
kann nie, wenn der jetzt mal sagt, ey, ich hätte mal Bock, keine Ahnung, mir einen neuen
Rechner zu kaufen, kann der nicht machen. Ja, wenn die jetzt sagen, ey, ich hätte mal
Bock, in den Urlaub zu fahren, können sie nicht machen. Wenn die sagen, fuck, unsere
Waschmaschine ist kaputt, muss ich voranweschen. Ja, also es ist wirklich der Wahnsinn, das
hält man gar nicht für möglich, aber gibt es genug und das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal,
bei uns im Stronksektor und da verdienen die Leute ja sicherlich, vielleicht nicht übermäßig
krass, aber also in der Position, wo er ist, aber zumindest über Mindestlohn und es gibt
bestimmt genug Leute, bei denen ist es sogar noch weniger als das. Chat sagt, man muss
den Flaschenhals ermitteln, wieso ist kein, das stimmt, ich bin zwar kein Stonksmann,
ja, ich hab ja, wie gesagt, von Finanzen, hab ich überhaupt keine Ahnung, aber was
mir auch schon aufgefallen ist, dass, zumindest bei denen, die ich kenne, worum es halt auch
aufgefallen ist, dass die eben durch diese, ja, von Paycheck zu Paycheck leben, die haben
oftmals so den Hang dazu, so merkwürdige, merkwürdige Dinger zu machen, wo dann das
Geld irgendwie drauf geht. Der eine zum Beispiel, der tuned ab und zu mal random sein Auto.
Wo ich mir auch denke, Alter, du hast kein Geld, die könnt euch keine Waschmaschine
kaufen, aber du tunes dein Auto. Wo ich mir auch denke, what the, aah, warum? Keine Ahnung,
weiß es nicht. Das verstehe ich auch nicht, aber eigentlich, wenn er Spaß dran hat, soll
er es machen. Das ist wirklich so, der hat mir erzählt, so nach dem Motto, sie können
sich keine, übertrieben, übertrieben sind es so nach dem Motto, wir können uns nicht
mal eine Waschmaschine kaufen, und dann hat er mir erzählt, er hat sich jetzt irgendwelche
Tuning-Teile für sein Audi bestellt. Ne, für sein BMW, nicht Audi. Hä? Hast du nicht
vor drei Wochen noch erzählt, überhaupt kein Geld, irgendwas zu kaufen? Ja, gut, aber Auto
getuned.
Ja, den kenne ich, von dem gucke ich tatsächlich manchmal, paar Videos. Habe ich den Chat eigentlich,
ich wollte mich jetzt eigentlich noch mal chibaten lassen, vor der Gamestar über Battlefield.
Am 11.11. wären die Leute wieder witzig, ja. Ich habe aber übrigens einen Corona-Test
gemacht. Ich hatte nichts, weil ich habe erfahren, dass bei uns jemand im Büro Corona hat. Ich
meine, ich bin doppelt geimpft, also sollte eigentlich nichts passieren, aber ich habe
erfahren, dass jemand im Büro, der lustigerweise auch gerade am Dienstag da war, wo ich auch
da war, vor Ort in Frankfurt, dass der Corona hat jetzt. Ich muss keinen Test machen, wir
können zweimal die Woche kostenlos einen Test machen, aber gezwungen hat mich dazu
noch keiner bisher.
Wie soll ich das noch machen? Zumindest ich habe heute einen Test gemacht, war aber negativ.
Also was ja positiv ist, dass er negativ war. War nichts. Zum Glück, ich dachte halt so,
hey, Dienstag war einer da mit Corona, heute hast du übertrieben Kopfweh und fühlst dich
so ein bisschen krank. Nicht, dass das doch Corona ist. Original Karat, danke für den
Sub. UWP, ja, deswegen, ich habe doch gesagt, Pain's Jam, UWP. UWP ist der größte Sack.
Ich hoffe, dass es Microsoft jetzt endlich mal mit WinUI und Windows App SDK, heißt das
glaube ich, hinbekommt, dass man unpackaged, gescheite unpackaged, ansprechende, moderne
unpackaged Windows Apps machen kann, das was jeder machen will. Da gibt es schon Tools
und das ist alles natürlich Spekulation. Man könnte sich Starlink kaufen und dann High
Frequency Trading, dann mache ich den HighFrequencyTradingChamp.org über Satellitenstells. Skylink. Tradechamp
mache ich dann. Stonkschamp, noch besser. Ach ja, hat er eigentlich geschrieben, wo
es um Einsteigerprogrammierkram ging oder war er schon wieder weg, ich war zu langsam.
Ja, das sage ich auch, ich würde heute auch mit JavaScript anfangen. Also wenn ich mit
was einsteigen müsste, ich keine Ahnung hätte, ich würde mit JavaScript anfangen. JavaScript
kommst du eh nicht dran vorbei, egal was du machst. Ein bisschen JavaScript musst du
immer können und man sieht halt, wenn was passiert. Ja, mache ich. Ja, es ist nicht
so, als hätte ich nicht was übrig, um was damit machen zu können, aber für mich sind
so Finanzthemen so richtig zäh. Das ist nichts, womit ich mich gerne beschäftige. Wahrscheinlich,
ja, wahrscheinlich. Klar, habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme damit. Ich bin das mittlerweile
sogar ganz entspannt. Ich habe ich habe schon mal aus Versehen, mal vor einer Weile, da
habe ich Twitch noch ein bisschen geguckt und auf einmal hat mein eigener Stream angefangen,
weil ich glaube, ich habe geguckt, was es für Clips gab vom aktuellen Tag und auf einmal
fing dann mein eigener Stream an. Ich sagte, ihr träumt ganz merkwürdige Sachen, wenn
ihr einpennt und euer Handy läuft und euer eigener Stream läuft. Da haben wir ganz komische
Dinge, irgendwas stimmt hier nicht. Aber mittlerweile habe ich mich da, also für die Stimme habe
ich mich schon lange dran gewöhnt. Ich meine, ich mache jetzt seit elf Jahren YouTube Videos,
ich habe mich selbst schon oft genug gehört und außerdem habe ich da bei meinem Headset
auch so eingestellt, dass ich mich selbst höre, weil ich sonst zu sehr schreie. Also
für mich hört sich meine Stimme in Videos mittlerweile genauso an wie meine Stimme über
so, wie heißt das so, Körperschall oder so. Natürlich ist es anders, aber ich weiß mittlerweile
einfach, dass es das gleiche ist. Da habe ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mehr mit. Ich
fand es am Anfang auch richtig painstjamp. Ich habe auch immer gedacht, Alter Max, du
hörst dich so scheiße an, warum hört sich das überhaupt jemand an? Denke ich eigentlich
immer noch, aber ich weiß, dass es halt ganz normal ist. Ja, so sieht es aus. Opel Agila
Master Race am Start. Was für ein Auto hast du? Ich habe ein 2001 in grün. So ein hier.
Gg Eats steht schon da. Ich gebe zu, dass es sicherlich kein Auto, wo ich auf YouTube
mit punkten kann, wenn ich sowas fahre. Ich fahre ja noch nicht mal viel. Gibt es ihn
auch in Forza 5? Was wäre es doch mal? Ich habe gehört, in Forza 5 gibt es den Teams
Sound als Klingelton. Morgen Battlefield ballern, klar. Schon ganz scharf drauf. Wobei ich mag
den. Ich mag den. Wisst ihr, was ich daran cool finde? Weiß ich, ob das daran liegt,
dass ich nicht der größte bin oder so. Ich bin 1,76. Knapp 1,76. Da muss ich mich schon
ganz besonders gerade hinstellen. Nein, auch nicht, weil der Umfeld beim Elch Test, das
war ein anderer. Nee, was mit dem cool ist, man sitzt ein bisschen höher. Ich mag das,
wenn man ein bisschen höher sitzt, dass man, weiß nicht, ob man sagen kann, dass man mehr
sieht. Aber ich finde das übersichtlicher und irgendwie angenehmer, wenn man weiter
oben sitzt. Klar, ich könnte mir auch eine SUV kaufen, dann sitze ich auch weiter oben.
Ah ja, Johnny ist der Beste, ihr guckt euch an. Johnny weiß Bescheid. Sollst du mal schnell
Chat durchmachen? Also Autos ist wirklich auch was, was mich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Es gibt so ein paar Themen, die gehen einfach voll an mir vorbei. Also in den Zeiten, wo
ich so aufgewachsen bin, war sich für Autos interessieren, also quasi mit das männlichste
Thema aller Zeiten. Keine Ahnung, ich habe mich nie für Autos interessiert. Was mein
Weg in der IT wird nun sein, re-zertifizierten LPG 1 plus 2, dann mal dritten für Secure
und dann auch mal, ich weiß nicht, ob die Zertifikate da irgendwas verbringen. Wenn
du, wenn du, sag mal, wenn du Value bringen, das wäre ja ein Scheißwort, wenn du wichtige
Sachen machst und die sicher gehen wollen, dass du bei ihnen bleibst, denke ich, jetzt
anfragen, sicherlich nicht das verkehrteste, was man machen kann. Man muss ja immer davon
achten, dass man sich die Leute ausreden lässt, weil es halt Budget spart. Und ich glaube,
die meisten Leute lassen sich zu einfach abspeisen. Ich will mich da gar nicht ausschließen.
Ich könnte sicherlich auch noch deutlich penetranter und nerviger sein wegen mehr Geld. Will ich
aber gerade gar nicht. Aber ich glaube, die meisten Leute würden mehr bekommen, wenn
sie es dann auch versuchen würden. Regelmäßig und mit Plan, ja. Es ist immer gut, also was
ich persönlich gut finde, ist, gerade wenn es dann wieder so diese Standardantworten
gibt nach dem Motto, was weiß ich, was man gemacht hat oder dass es gerade ja ganz schlecht
ist, es ist immer schlecht. Prinzipiell ist es immer schlecht, der Zeitpunkt, wenn man
fragt, also zumindest ist das so meine Erfahrung, immer wenn man fragt, es ist gerade ganz schlecht,
es ist gerade Corona, es ist gerade Budgetplanung, es ist gerade Ende des Jahres, es ist gerade
Anfang des Jahres, es ist gerade Mitte des Jahres, es ist gerade Sommerpause, es ist was
auch immer, es kommt immer irgendwas, warum das angeblich nicht geht. Das ist so Standardkram.
Wenn man da dann schon aufhört mit, dann gibt es halt auch nichts. Also was ich immer
ganz gut finde, immer wenn man was Cooles gemacht hat, was eventuell auch ein bisschen
außerhalb vom eigenen Team angekommen ist, ich habe da so eine Textdatei und da schreibe
ich mir alles rein, alles, was gut angekommen ist. Zum Beispiel stehen da so Sachen drin,
das ist das erste, was mir jetzt einfällt, weil ich habe da morgen witzigerweise gerade
reingeguckt, das ist eines der Sachen, die relativ weit oben steht. Zum Beispiel, die
Geschichte habe ich euch auch schon mal erzählt, die Log-Auswertung für unsere Proxys. Die
Admin-Hackermans haben ein Skript gebastelt in Bash, was zwei Wochen gelaufen ist, ich
bin hingegangen, habe dort ein Core-Programm gebastelt, was das irgendwie in einer Viertelstunde
gemacht. Weil Multithreaded-Log-Auswertung auf einer 48-Core-CPU-Kiste ist halt schon
ordentlich. Das sind so Sachen, die schreibe ich mir einfach immer mal auf zwischendurch,
dass man die bei der passenden Gelegenheit dann mal aufs Brot schmieren kann und sagen,
ja guck mal hier, was das wieder für Zeit gespart hat. Aber ja, es wird immer irgendwas
sein, was angeblich nicht passt. Ja, das ist auch eine coole Sache, wenn das geht.
Ganz ehrlich, Zertifikate sind nicht das, was dein Wert irgendwie gut verkauft, ja.
Also es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, je nachdem, ob dein Laden auf Zertifikate steht
oder nicht. Klar, kann schon was bringen. Eventuell für einen neuen Job kann das sicherlich
auch was bringen und wissenmäßig mag dir das auch was bringen. Aber das ist im Endeffekt
dann nicht, also meiner Einschätzung, ich bin kein Personalmensch, aber meiner Einschätzung
ist das nicht unbedingt das, was jetzt den wahnsinnig ausschlaggebenden Punkt gibt.
Doch die Inflationsrate jetzt ist nicht mit letzten Oktober von September auf Oktober
die 4,5 Prozent. Innerhalb von einem Monat. Exzellent, hier richtigen Easy Money Leute
wieder im Chat. Ich glaube, ich komme mit dem Chat heute näher. Ja, doch, doch, komm mal,
ich bin fast unten, ich bin fast unten. Ja man, das kann man halt nachhinein schlecht
sagen, weil man weiß nicht, wie hart es gewesen wäre, wenn sie nicht geimpft gewesen wäre.
Ja, die wollen wieder Impfzentren machen, das finde ich auch lustig, erst dicht machen
und jetzt wieder sagen, oh Mist, konnte ja keiner mit rechnen, wir machen mal wieder
auf. Ja, hoffen wir mal. Der Krypto-Champ. Du hast gerade View-Elektronen-Typescript
gemacht, habe nun 4 Tage meinen Kopf gegen die Wand gehauen, bis alles geklappt hat.
Kein Tutorial hat funktioniert, irgendwas immer Outland, IPC ist so unglaublich unintuitive.
Das habe ich glaube ich noch nie gemacht. Was IPC's du denn, also was kommunizierst
du denn? Weil Elektron an sich, du hast ja einmal Node-Share-Runtime und du hast V8,
aber das ist doch in Elektron alles eingebaut, dass es miteinander kommunizieren kann. Also
du meinst doch das ja. Ok, das hatte ich jetzt gar nicht, ich habe mit Elektronen nicht wirklich
viel gemacht, aber das hatte ich jetzt nicht so als Painz-Champ im Hinterkopf. Jeder was
ihm gefällt, ja. Wir können ja wieder PokeV-Virtual-Check machen. Oh ne, das darf man auf Twitch nicht
mal sagen. Toss, Alter. Ja, ja, wir gucken uns jetzt das Gamestar-Video noch an, ich
habe ja noch kurz Zeit. Das Motor geflasht, der Tesla, das wär's ja. Das gilt aber nur
für Leute, die wirklich gut sind in dem was sie machen, das ist vielleicht 20% der Leute.
Ich glaube sogar, dass es ein bisschen weniger noch ist, um ehrlich zu sein. Aber ja, du
hast schon recht, also ich sag ja meistens 90, wahrscheinlich hast du recht, wahrscheinlich
sind 80%, also 80% die Kacke sind 20%, die was können, realistischer. Ich sag ja immer
90, 10%, aber wahrscheinlich sind 80, 20%, aber natürlich hat er Ahnung, weil er guckt
hier zu. Und alle die hier zugucken wissen wir ja schon aus Prinzip, sind IQ-mäßig
natürlich weit, weit oben, allein schon durch die ganzen Prime-Subs, die es gegeben hat.
Und ihr wisst ja, jeder Prime-Sub gibt so kollektiv einen IQ-Punkt für jeden. IQ++,
das zeigt. Ja, da muss ich sagen, das hat sich bei uns deutlich verbessert, seitdem,
ich will es mir nicht auf meine Fahne schreiben, beim besten Willen nicht alleine, aber seitdem
wir da angefangen haben offener miteinander zu reden, machen auch mehr Leute mit. Stimmt
eigentlich, wenn alle schon super high IQ haben, dann subben sie nicht mehr, weil mehr
IQ brauchst du irgendwann, irgendwann ist ja mal Schluss. Aber was ich euch nicht erzählt
hab, um die Abo-Falle perfekt zu machen ist, das verfällt natürlich auch wieder, wenn
man nicht regelmäßig subbt. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man einmal subbt, IQ-Punkte
abgreifen kann und dann nie wieder hier auftauchen muss. Das muss schon refreshed werden, sonst
funktioniert das nicht. Aber das sage ich natürlich nicht so offen, sonst würden die
Leute das ja merken mit der Prime-Abo-Falle. Scamast, ja. Schaut doch mal, ich gucke das
GameStar-Video gleich. Erstmal Chat fertig lesen. Achso, ja, das bringt natürlich was,
ja klar. Also was lernen dafür, lernen ist immer nicht schlecht. Das ist eh übrigens
eine Sache, ich als Nicht-Stonks-Mann, muss ich das jetzt einfach mal sagen, ich glaube,
das beste in was man investieren kann ist eigenes Gehirn. Also klar, natürlich geldtechnisch
mag anderes vielleicht Potenzial haben für mehr Geld, aber ich glaube, eine Sache, wo
man nie falsch liegen kann ist, in sein eigenes Know-How und Bildung und Gehirn zu investieren.
Das wird sich wahrscheinlich über kurz oder lang immer auszahlen. Ich kann es mir schon
vorstellen. Das kann man nicht so einfach programmieren, wenn ich das wüsste, dann
wäre ich reich. Unlucky Dog, danke für den Sub. Ja genau, ich verstehe es auch nicht
genau, warum die Leute über ihr Gehalt nicht reden wollen. Im Prinzip hast du eigentlich
nur Vorteile davon, ich glaube, es liegt daran, wenn ich ehrlich bin, also kenne ich das früher
von mir selbst, mittlerweile ist es nichts, aber früher kenne ich es von mir selbst. Man
redet nicht über das Gehalt, weil man insgeheim Angst hat, dass andere, die das gleiche wie
du machen, deutlich mehr bekommen. So bescheuert war ich am Anfang auch, ich habe gedacht,
besser rede ich nicht drüber, wie dass ich mitkriege, dass der andere 5k mehr wie ich
verdient und weniger macht. So, aber das ist bescheuert, weil eigentlich müsste das Datensatz
sein, dass du mehr kriegst. Oh, ich habe den Chat geschafft, ok, exellent. Jetzt kann ich
tatsächlich das Gamestar Video gucken. Wo ist das Gamestar Video? Battlefield ist gut,
darf aber so nicht erscheinen. Das erscheint aber morgen. Oder ist das Clickbait? Ist das
Gbaitetitel? Leute, wir müssen reden über Battlefield 2042 und den Zustand des Spiels
zum Release. Denn klar, es gab nach der Beta bereits diverse Warnsignale, über die wir
auch in unseren letzten Videos zum Spiel schon gesprochen hatten. Ja, ich habe ja auch ein
Video zugemacht, also ich meine, dass ich mangelhaft draufgeschrieben habe, war vielleicht
ein Appetit Anreger, um da rauf zu klicken. Aber im Prinzip stimmt es ja, was ich gesagt
habe.
Wir waren aber nach den vielen angekündigten Verbesserungen von DICE optimistisch, dass
dem Team trotzdem ein ordentlicher Launch gelingen kann. Mein Kollege Dmitri Haller hat das fertige
Spiel jetzt in einem von DICE veranstalteten Testevent gespielt und durchaus seinen Spaß
damit gehabt. Gleichzeitig sagte er aber auch, so hätte Battlefield 2042 nicht erscheinen
dürfen. Deshalb gibt es von uns auch heute schon dieses Video. Na gut, das ist ja nichts
Neues. Das ist ja in allen Battlefields schon so gewesen, dass du komische Fahrzeugphysik
hattest.
Wenn du um 22 Uhr schlafen gehst, wann stehst du immer so auf, um 7 Uhr oder so? Bevor wir
jetzt gleich darüber sprechen, was bei Battlefield 2042 schon gut gelungen ist, wo es aber immer
noch Probleme gibt, sollten wir vielleicht am Anfang mal diesen ganzen Umstand mit dem
Testevent erklären. Wie lief denn das ab?
Ja, das Wichtigste zuerst. Ich habe mir gestern beim Dyremessen voll auf die Zunge gebissen
und deswegen lalle ich ein wenig. Also es liegt nicht daran, ausnahmsweise nicht daran,
dass ich im Vorfeld vor dem Dreh ein bisschen was gebe.
Kommt vor.
Genau, also sorry, was war noch? Ah ja, Battlefield. Genau, das Review-Event war...
Hätte er sich mal einen Köfte-Teller bestellt, da wäre sowas nicht passiert.
Eine holprige Angelegenheit, sowohl in der Zeit, die ich hatte zum Spielen, als auch
in der Umsetzung konkret. Ich hatte jetzt de facto drei Abende Zeit Battlefield zu spielen,
pro Modus ein Abend. Das heißt, ich habe jetzt de facto ein paar...
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, das Event war Dienstag, Mittwoch, Donnerstag, ich habe
das ja, ähm, Montag, Dienstag, Mittwoch und man konnte, genau, man konnte pro Tag irgendwie
einen anspielen. Hab ich auch gerüchteweise gehört...
Ich erinnere mich natürlich nicht von wem. Ja, und daraufhin habe ich mal gefragt, warum
haben sie mich nicht eingeladen, haben sie nicht darauf geantwortet, aber sie haben gesagt,
es war nur ein sehr limitiertes Kontingent verfügbar.
Genau, okay, dann halt nicht. Ich glaube, es liegt daran, weil ich zu viel
geflamed habe im Vorfeld. Ich meine, ich habe ja schon ein äußerst
kritisches Video gemacht über die Beta, vielleicht wollte man das nicht, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht bin ich auch zu unbedeutend, was auch durchaus sein kann, ich meine, die Battlefield-Videos
hatten zwar viele Aufrufe, irgendwie 60, 70k, aber im großen Gesamt der Dinge ist das
natürlich nicht sonderlich bedeutend.
Ein paar Matches Breakthrough, ein paar Matches Portal und ein paar Matches Hazard Zone, das
reicht natürlich nie und nimmer für einen finalen Eindruck aller Bereiche von Battlefield
2049.
Wisst ihr, er hat Recht, er hat Recht, er hat vollkommen Recht, aber, aber, wisst ihr,
warum er diesen Disclaimer am Anfang bringen muss? Weil sonst die Battlefield-Fans, also
diese ultra Battlefield-Fanboys, die rasten sonst wieder aus.
Das ist ein Punkt, das musst du leider heutzutage überall machen davor.
So nach dem Motto, du kannst nicht einfach sagen, okay, meine Meinung über das Game,
das finde ich nicht gut, das finde ich nicht gut, das muss verbessert werden, weil so und
so, das reicht nicht. Du musst immer anfangen mit, ja, aus meiner Sicht ist das so, obwohl
es natürlich im Großen und Ganzen ein gutes Spiel ist, aber im Detail, aber das kann sich
ja auch schon wieder alles ändern, je nachdem, was im nächsten Patch kommt. Du musst es
halt mittlerweile so ultra weich spülen, ich kenne das ja selbst auf YouTube, sonst rasten
die Leute alle voll aus.
So, weiter.
Balancing im Detail stimmt, ob es eine Waffe gibt, die zu stark ist, ob die Specialists
am Ende irgendwelche unfairen Vorteile haben oder so, so bestimmte Dinge kann ich einfach
nicht einschätzen.
Und dieses Event war natürlich auch ein sehr ambitioniertes Unterfangen von DICE, sage
ich mal, weil sie Leute von der ganzen Welt bzw. aus Europa, aus Nordamerika, aus allen
möglichen Ländern miteinander verbinden mussten, sodass sie...
Ich hätte so gerne mal Levelcap Chebated in Battlefield. Der Chebatet uns jeden Sonntag
mit seinen Videos. Der hätte ich ihn auch gerne mal, wenigstens in-game Chebated mit
den Serbern reibungslos spielen können, mit all ihren PCs und Racks und so weiter. Das
hat natürlich nicht gut funktioniert. Also ich habe auch Mitgefühl mit DICE, dass sie
das versucht haben, aber es gab viele Verbindungsprobleme, die jetzt mit der finalen Version nichts mehr
zu tun haben. Aber das war quasi die Grundlage.
Endlich haben sie mal einen genommen, der halbwegs was trifft. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr
das letzte Preview-Video von der GameStar gesehen habt. Der, der mit dem letzten Preview-Video
gespielt hat, das war das größte PP-GA-Aim, was ich jemals gesehen habe. Er trifft ja
wenigstens, obwohl es Bots sind. Egal.
Ich kann bestimmte Dinge einfach noch nicht einschätzen.
Es ist noch zu früh, dass wir eine Form von Wertung geben, deswegen jetzt auch kein fein
säuberliches Testvideos.
Moment, da steht Test-Fazit. Warum steht da Test-Fazit, wenn es keine Bewertung gibt?
Keck Wade. Test-Fazit steht da. Da würde ich sagen, der Test ist schon fertig.
Massive G-Bade.
Schnelle Talk zwischen uns beiden. Du hast aber eben schon angesprochen, es gab diverse
technische Probleme, die aber auch mit dieser ganzen Testevent-Situation zu tun hatten.
Aber wie lief denn sonst diese Release-Version zumindest nach den paar Abenden, die du bisher
da spielen konntest?
Das ist mein Fazit zum Testevent. Dann habe ich mich verlesen, das ist mein Fazit, ja
ein Test-Fazit.
Naja.
Ich würde sagen, das sollte man jetzt schon releasen. Das klingt sehr hart, aber ist
tatsächlich das, was ich gespielt habe, ist die Release-Version. Das hat DICE auch betont.
Da wird es jetzt bis zu diesem Soft-Launch am 12. November.
Es gibt einen riesen Day-One-Patch, das wissen wir.
Nach ein paar Tage später noch mal ein Patch kommt, weiß ich nicht. Aber das, was ich
jetzt für diesen Test gespielt habe, ist die Version, die man dann eben auch öffentlich
spielen kann ab 12. November. Und die lief nicht super sauber. Also wirklich nicht.
Sie lief deutlich besser als die Beta, die ja sehr kontrovers war, aber es gab dann immer
wieder Bugs.
Leute konnten sich nicht wiederbeleben in Matches, was gerade bei Hazard Zone echt mal
nervt. Irgendwie in der Distanz glitchen Leute rum. Es gab viele von diesen typischen Glitch-
und Pop-In-Fehlern.
Ja, das dachte ich mir.
Das war auch im Prinzip das, was ich in meinem, was alles an der Beta nicht gut war, gesagt
habe, dass viele Sachen sicherlich gepatcht werden können, aber manche Sachen sind halt
einfach by design. Zum Beispiel wie die Maps. Und das so Glitch-Zeug am Anfang, am Start,
das hätte, glaube ich, keiner anders erwartet als bei Battlefield. Leider. Ich glaube, die
letzten zwei Battlefields sind, glaube ich, ziemlich gut gelauncht. Aber davor war alles
immer ziemlich pepega.
Genom nicht game-breaking. Also nur weil man mal eine Runde nicht wiederbeleben kann, natürlich
stirbt damit nicht der Spaß am Battlefield.
Aber ich kann nicht sagen, dass das nicht das ist, was nachhaltig so ein Problem werden
könnte, wenn halt sehr viele Leute, davon auch schwieriger betroffen sind. Viele haben
über die Performance geklagt, teilgenommen haben an diesem Event, das gab es in der 2080,
die unter 30 FPS rumgeguckt sind, was halt eigentlich nicht sein darf. Ich hatte jetzt
3070 im Rechner. Da lief es gut. Da lief es wirklich gut.
Was mache ich mit meiner 1080C? Ich bin ja mal echt gespannt darauf, wie das morgen
läuft. Aber ich stelle die Details eh runter.
Aber ich sage mal, also wenn ihr zu den glücklichen gehört, die eine 3080 haben, dann habt ihr
wahrscheinlich auch eine PS5 und das ist dann also Glück für euch. Aber es kann halt sein,
je nachdem, welchen Rechner ihr habt, dass das Spiel Probleme macht. Und auch da schäle
ich.
Ich würde jetzt zur Beta Kritik vor allem für fehlende Features, die man aus Vorgängern
schon kannte. Also eine Beta war ja zum Beispiel das Comoros nicht drin. Die Karte hat nicht
funktioniert.
Das Scoreboard war kacke.
Ist dir da was aufgefallen, was da ist ja eigentlich versprochen worden.
Ich hoffe, das Scoreboard wird besser. Aber ich bilde mir ein, schon das Scoreboard gesehen
zu haben in einem anderen Video und das war nicht besser.
Ich hatte zu reparieren, bis zur Vollversion, was immer noch fehlt.
Da haben sie viel gemacht. Also die Lesbarkeit von Battlefield 2042 hat sich drastisch verbessert.
Ja, das sieht viel klarer aus, ja, viel klarer. Das stimmt. Das fällt noch sofort auf.
Die Comoros funktioniert jetzt, das Spotten funktioniert. Generell auch die über, also
quasi die Map, wo man alles sieht, die Übersichtskarte, dass man genau erkennen kann, wo gerade die
Action ab oder so.
Aber wisst ihr, was ich immer noch ein bisschen doof finde, dass man nicht, also das fand
ich ja gerade in Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 teilweise gut. Du konntest jetzt nicht,
also du konntest jetzt nicht den hier auswählen und siehst dann, was um den Drumherum passiert.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, ich kann doch nicht anhand dieser Map einschätzen, ob es jetzt
safe ist, bei ihm zu spawnen oder nicht. Wie? Ich meine, hier würde ich sagen, okay, ist
vielleicht keine so gute Idee, wenn es jetzt kein Panzer wäre. Aber ansonsten kannst du
das doch anhand dieser Map absolut nicht erkennen.
Also ich bin mit der UI eigentlich relativ zufrieden. Es ist so ein bisschen kompliziert,
wie dieses ganze Ding funktioniert mit dem, wann du aufschlägst.
Ey, das sieht ein bisschen aus wie Parasite Storm, oder?
Wobei das dann doch nicht da hinten, aber hier am Anfang.
Da hast du halt deine Sammlung im Menü, wo du alles irgendwie vorher auswählen kannst,
was du mitnehmen willst in das Match mit deiner Waffe.
Und ich sage euch jetzt auch schon eins, die Wettereffekte, die werden abfacken mit der
Zeit. Das habe ich von Anfang an gesagt und ich habe auch viele Sachen gesagt, über
das Game, die vielleicht nicht so sind. Aber bei den Wettereffekten bin ich mir sicher,
die werden nerven mit der Zeit.
Bei den anderen Modi ist das ein bisschen komplizierter, aber insgesamt ist das haben
sie gegen...
Die haben mich in dem Anspiel, die werden schon genervt.
Das war ja eine der großen Kritikpunkte.
Dann lass uns jetzt mal im weiteren Verlauf des Videos diese drei großen Säulen von
Battlefield 2042 gesondert ansprechen und ich würde sagen, den Anfang machen wir einfach
mit dem klassischen Modus, nämlich All-Out-Warfare. Da gab es jetzt im Vorfeld auch schon wieder
so ein bisschen Verunsicherung, weil rausgekommen war, dass es in dieser Release-Version wohl
nur verhältnismäßig wenig Waffen geben soll. Was weißt du denn darüber?
Das wird auch so sein. Also es sind, glaube ich, 22 Waffen.
Das bedeutet, Season Pass und naja, 22 Waffen aufgeteilt auf, sagen wir mal, vier Klassen.
Drei Specialist und so, aber Waffen sind ja allgemein gültig, aber wahrscheinlich werden
sich die unterschiedlich...
Also für unterschiedliche Klassen werden sich wahrscheinlich nach wie vor unterschiedliche
Waffen anbieten, muss man mal gucken.
Ich meine, Recon werden die meisten mit Sniper spielen, wohingegen Assault wahrscheinlich
die meisten mit Assault Rifle spielen, aber ansonsten finde ich 21 Waffen, wenn die schön
unterschiedlich sind, in Ordnung.
Die sich auf sieben Kategorien verteilen und das sind dann teilweise recht wenige Waffen
pro Kategorie.
Also ich glaube zwei LMGs, drei Schussflügel, drei Sniper, drei Assault Rifles, das ist
überschaubar.
Ich finde es okay.
Ist tatsächlich auch etwas, was langfristig vielleicht zu einem Problem werden kann.
Also ich finde es okay, wenn das halt so ist, dass die Dinger sich unterscheiden, dass
es also auch wirklich Impact hat, was du nimmst.
Ja, sagen wir mal den Unterschied von einem Battlefield 3, sagen wir mal den Unterschied
von der AEK zu der AN-490 oder sowas oder gucken wir mal zu Bad Company 2, da hast du
eine M60 als LMG oder eine M240, das war jetzt komplett unterschiedliche Waffe, dann finde
ich das gut.
Wenn das alles quasi abklatscht voneinander ist...
Natürlich im Battlefield Portal viel mehr Waffen als aus älteren Battlefields, aber
in All-Out Warfare ist das Arsenal relativ beschränkt.
Es kann natürlich sein, dass im Endeffekt die Waffen sich aber langfristig so gut ausbalancieren
und so, dass es sogar die richtige Entscheidung war, da auf wenig zu setzen.
Wenn das so ist, ja.
Aber ich kann verstehen, wenn das erstmal ein bisschen weniger...
Das finde ich jetzt gar nicht so schlimm.
Aber ich hatte trotzdem mit All-Out Warfare saumäßig viel Spaß, das muss man einfach
mal so klar sagen.
Conquest und Breakthrough, die zwei Untermodi von All-Out Warfare, das hat super funktioniert.
Die 128 Spieler haben sich auch nicht negativ ausgewirkt.
Dass es jetzt totale Choke Points gibt in Breakthrough, weil alles sich an einen Punkt
knüpft oder so.
Es gibt ja gerade leider bei diesen Maps so gut wie keine Choke Points, also die sind
halt offen und es ist nichts drauf.
Battlefield 5 durchaus mal ein Problem sein konnte, schon bei 64 Spielern, war da gar
nicht das Problem.
Die sind alle ein bisschen wie Orbital und Orbital war auch schon zu offen.
...All-Out Warfare schon sehr entfaltet, dieses Taktieren im Squad, wo man jetzt irgendwie
genau angreifen will, dann diese verrückten Manöver, die man mit dem Fahrzeugen macht,
dass man irgendwie mit einem Schlauchboden in die generische Basis reinfährt oder mit
einem Jet über die Karte fliegt, rausspringt, einen Panzer aus der Luft wegmacht mit der
K.
Gustav, sich halt voll reinstürzt, da wo halt heftig gekämpft wird oder aber sich halt
an einen Punkt heranschleicht mit seinem Squad, also typische Backdoor-Aktionen probiert.
Das war alles drin, das was Battlefield cool macht, diese Multi-Layer Sandbox.
Das stimmt, das hat man in der Beta auch schon gemerkt.
Neu ist aber ja jetzt in Battlefield 2042 dieses Specialist-System.
Was hältst du von einer Waffe pro Klasse, die dann perfekt ausgebalanced ist?
Na, eine Waffe ist ein bisschen wenig, ich meine, ich guck mal sogar in Battlefield 2
gab es schon, ich glaub, zwei Waffen pro Klasse oder so, ne, das ist ein bisschen wenig.
Aber ich finde Masse, also ich finde Klasse statt Masse auch besser.
Das alte Klassen-System, ich sag mal ja ersetzt, wo es im Vorfeld viel Kritik gab und Befürchtungen,
dass da bestimmte Specialists zu mächtig wären, dass die Übersicht flöchelig ist.
Wird auch sein.
Ich sag euch, wenn Webstar noch so ist wie in der Beta, ist Must-Have-OPS-Fuck.
Erfahrungen mit den Specialists.
Die wirken sich auf jeden Fall aus, also dieses klassische Klassen-System von Battlefield,
das wird stark abgeschwächt dadurch, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Leute mit diesem
neuen Specialist-System ernsthaft noch darüber nachdenken werden, gezielt Versorger zu spielen
oder Medics zu spielen, das kannst du ja nach wie vor, du kannst ja jetzt völlig frei dir
dein Loadout zusammenstellen und entscheiden, welche Rolle du spielen möchtest, ohne dass
du eingeschränkt bist bei deinen Waffen oder so, was ja prinzipiell cool ist, ich kann
mir nur wirklich vorstellen, es war ja eh immer schon Battlefield-Problem, dass die Leute
nicht Objective spielen und nicht teamorientiert spielen, dass das sich jetzt noch weiter auffechert.
Muss man sich die Specialist kaufen, nee.
Die sind free, ich weiß gar nicht, wie es mit Anlocken aussieht ehrlich gesagt.
Potenziales Problem, jetzt natürlich bei dem Review-Event habe ich mit Leuten zusammengespielt,
die Battlefield kennen, also wirklich schon lange kennen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass
die Specialists die Battlefield-Erfahrung komplett kaputt machen werden, also es ist
nicht so, dass aus Battlefield jetzt ein Hero-Shooter wird, wo alle mit Wardrobe rumlaufen
oder überall Wingsuits durch die Landschaft fliegen oder mit Grapple-Hooks halt irgendwie,
die alles da am Rumsleiden ist.
Das nicht, aber das mit dem Grapple-Hook, ich bin da immer noch skeptisch.
Also ihr habt es in der Beta gesehen, ich habe das ja auch ein bisschen gestreamt, also
Webster mit dem Grappling-Hook, wenn das noch so funktioniert wie in der Beta, dann ist
das schon echt grenzwertig OP.
Ich meine, du kannst mit Webster zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal das Gebäude hier, du kannst
Mobility-mäßig einfach aufs Dach, wo eventuell sonst keiner hin kann, also das ist schon
echt richtig heftig.
Also du hast schon alles sehr Battlefield-mäßig, also du hast deine großen Panzer, die immer
mit Geschwindigkeit, die Flaschen, die sind fachlich, bestimmen, auch die Helikopter usw.,
dass wer eine Panzerhoheit aufbaut, da kann auch kein Specialist was gegen tun, so wirkt
es auf mich bisher.
Auch bei den Waffen, das wirkt ja auch so, was ich sehr cool fand bei Gunplay zum Beispiel,
ist, dass die Waffen sehr klare Grenzen haben, du kannst mit dem Sturmgewehr auf schon längere
Distanzen, mittlere längere Distanzen, wenig ausrichten, der Recoil ist extrem.
Das habe ich auch gedacht am Anfang in der Beta, bis ich dann darauf gekommen bin, es
kann sein, dass sich es im Release geändert hat, bis ich dann darauf gekommen bin, das
Einzige, was diese Waffen wirklich haben und was das Handling schwer macht, ist, dass die
einen ziemlichen Kick haben am Anfang, also die Waffen in Battlefield haben initial einen
relativ hohen Kick, danach sind die aber easy as fuck zu kontrollieren.
Also du kannst mit einem Vierfach ACOG, also noch nicht, man braucht nicht mal einen Vierfach
ACOG, aber what the fuck, warum sind es auf einmal 400 Zuschauer, was ist denn jetzt los,
hat mich jemand ghost und ich habe es nicht gesehen, oder ist Twitch kaputt?
Habe ich irgendwas, habe ich irgendwas, was, what the fuck, ja ich, alles klar, null, habe
ich irgendwas übersehen?
Danke schön für den Host, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich in ein paar Minuten aufgehen, danke
für den Host, ja, ja war es gut, null, das ist natürlich jetzt bester Content, wir gucken
das GameStar Video, es ist quasi, noch nicht mal mein Content, aber egal, wir gucken uns
das jetzt weiter an und ich gebe mal weiter meinen Senf dazu, wie gesagt, also ich dachte,
dass bei den Battlefield 2042 Waffen auch, dass die schwierig zu kontrollieren sind,
aber der initiale Kick bei den Waffen ist das, was die schwierig macht, danach sind
die ziemlich einfach zu bedienen, einfach zu handeln.
Und du musst wirklich sehr hart versuchen, diesen Recall zu meistern, um damit auf Mittel-Distanz
gut zu sein.
Und Burst ist halt wegen dem initialen Kick gar nicht mal so gut, guck mal, wenn du jetzt
Burstest oder Single-Schuss machst, dann macht der halt initial mal so einen Kick, die Waffe,
so einen Kick, aber der weitere Recoil ist dann relativ easy zu managen, also du musst
eigentlich nur den initialen Kick ausgleichen und dann leicht nach unten ziehen und schon
bist du mehr oder weniger auch auf längere Range ziemlich gut Dauer, Feuer, Abenteuer
drauf.
Mal abwarten, wie es im fertigen Game sein wird, um einen Kill zu machen, also ich sehe
da halt sehr viel, was ich meistern kann als Spieler und das ist das, was ich immer cool
finde.
Kann mir vorstellen, dass es aber auch Leute gibt, die das eher nicht so cool finden, also
dass man da irgendwie noch Tweaks einbauen soll, aber prinzipiell Waffengeschick, Fahrzeugüberlegenheit,
Strategie beim Oberverpunkten, dass du nach wie vor die Dinge, die entscheiden, ob du
in einem Battlefield-Match gewinnst oder nicht, ob jetzt aber der Wallhack, also dieser Wallhack
von dieser, glaube ich, koreanischen Spezialistin oder der Greifhaken oder dieser...
Die koreanische Spezialistin, der Helm sieht so unglaublich dumm aus, BF2HK, Specialist,
das sieht so... alter, dieser Helm, wer bei DICE hat sich gedacht... das ist eine Brille,
ja, aber wer bei DICE hat sich gedacht, jawoll, lass uns die Brille mal so an den Helm pappen.
Das sieht einfach nur doof aus.
Zack, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Ganz Körperschild oder so, ob das dazu führt, dass wenn die Leute das rauskriegen, es ein
Exploit wird, dass alle nur noch mit diesem Körperschild rumlaufen.
Ich kann es nicht abschätzen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Spezialist jetzt per se die
Battlefield-Erfahrungen ruinieren werden.
Also wie gesagt, es ist halt nur deine Erfahrung dieses Testevents, ob da sich jetzt irgendeine
verrückte Exploit mitkommt.
Gibt es doch in echt auch so, selbst wenn es in echt gibt, das sieht einfach bescheuert
aus.
Ja.
Das werden die nächsten Tage jetzt zeigen.
Dann sprechen wir nochmal über den ganz neuen Modus, wie DICE zumindest sagt, in Battlefield,
nämlich Hazard Zone, der durchaus Anleihen bei anderen Spielen hat, wie Escape from Tarkov
oder auch Hunt.
In Battlefield ist das aber neu, das konntet ihr jetzt auch ausprobieren, wie ist denn
der?
DICE glaube ich die größte Baustelle, die das Spiel hat.
Hazard Zone hat sehr gute Ideen, was kein Wunder ist, weil die Ideen stammen aus Hunt,
der beste Shooter der Welt.
Seht ihr, seht ihr Leute, könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als wir das erste Reveal-Video
herangeguckt haben, das erste, was wir hier auch gesagt haben, unter Chat auch, das ist
übelst an Hunt angelehnt und es ist es im Endeffekt auch.
Er hat sehr gute Ideen, es ist ja dieses, du bist in einem Squad aus vier Leuten, du
infiltrierst, die Jäger lehren große Karten.
Es ist ja auch spieleübergreifend, also so wie ich das verstanden hab, ich hab mir das
auch nochmal in diesem Briefing-Dokument angeguckt, also anscheinend ist es ja wirklich so, Hazard
Zone geht über mehrere Runden, also levelst dich dann quasi auf und spielst ne Runde,
levelst dich auf und dann hast du dann dein Zeug, kannst Zeug zwischen den Runden kaufen.
Was ist Hunt?
Ja das, guck mal deine Finger, aber ich mein Hunt, das Crytek, dieses Crytek, wie heißt
denn das?
Hunt Showdown?
Oder wie heißt das korrekt?
Das ist von Crytek dieses, das ist ja nicht wirklich Battle Royale, das Ding von Crytek.
Andere Leute, die hier da am Karren fahren wollen und das Ziel ist für alle Teams Datenkassetten
zu extrahieren aus dieser Zone und es gibt auch KI-Gegner, die das auch nochmal erschweren
und du hast halt zwei Möglichkeiten pro Match zu extrahieren, wenn du das beide Male verpasst.
Ja also du sammelst irgendwie XP, genau sammelst XP, wenn du Bots und Spieler killst, kannst
du dich auflöpeln, also eher Tarkov als Battle Royale und das ist von der Idee cool und es
gibt da auch sehr coole Momente, wenn das klappt, wenn man irgendwie letzte Sekunde
mit nem Jeep abhaut, währenddessen wird man verfolgt und man verteidigt diese Exfiltrationszone
oder wenn man halt ein anderes Team überrascht, während es gerade gegen wiederum ein anderes
Team käme, also man diese Sandwich Momente hat, das ist alles sehr cool, aber Hazard
Zone hat massive Balancing Probleme, also wirklich massive Balancing Probleme, das Ding ist komplett
einsteigerfeindlich, weil diese Ingame Economy nicht funktioniert, du wählst vor dem Match
dein Loadout aus und du hast, wenn du kein Geld hast, Ingame Geld, nur die Möglichkeit
eine popelige Sturmgewehrwaffe mitzunehmen, dieses Sturmgewehr bringt dir auf fast keine
Distanz was, nur auf Kurzdistanz, das ist wirklich eine total schlechte Waffe und wenn
du aber nicht viele NPCs killst, wenn du nicht Spieler killst, wenn du keine Extraktion
schaffst oder so, dann steigt dein Konto nur sehr sehr langsam und mal was anderes als
Waffe mitzunehmen ist halt sau teuer, also du musst wirklich grinden und was dazu kommt,
man kann es ja wohl nicht von Gegnern looten, soweit ich das jetzt im Vorfeld raus bekommen
habe, du kannst wohl nicht, das werden wir morgen sehen, du kannst wohl nicht den Gegner
killen und dann einfach sein gutes Kit nehmen, du musst wirklich diesen Ingame XP grind
machen, kann ich dazu das sagen, aber ich muss das spielen Leute, ich muss das spielen,
weil ich hab meine Seele verkauft an EA für drei Videos und da ist unter anderem einmal
Vorstellungen Herrsatz auch dabei, du bist halt taktisch komplett festgefahren auf dieses
ich bin mit dem Sturmgewehr, versuche ich halt jedes mal irgendwie NPCs zu killen und
nicht rasiert zu werden von Leuten, die halt viel besser sind, das heißt du gurgst halt
etisch mit extrem, versuchst du, außer du gewinnst ja ja morgen klar, schwimmst du
im Geld und kannst dir von diesem Geld nichts kaufen als halt noch mal dieselben Startwaffen
für die Partien danach, das heißt ein Hunt Shoulder z.B. hat viel, viel ausgeklügeltere
Mechaniken, auf wie vielen Ebenen es dich für was lohnt, mit was du rauskommst, Captain
Peng morgen kommen wir spielen, ich sag dann im Discord Bescheid, wenn du ein Match verlierst,
wie man halt auch Neulinge schützt, dass du beispielsweise nicht alles verlieren kannst,
wenn du ein Neuling bist, dass du auch permanent Auswahl bekommst an Startwaffen, selbst wenn
du keine Siege erziehst, also all diese feinen Mechaniken hat Hazard Zone halt nicht und
ein zweites Problem, die NPCs sind zu krass, also diese NPCs rasieren die auf 200 mit Augenbrauen
weg, die zielen halt so hart.
Ich hab in der Beta, das muss ich jetzt mal kurz erzählen zu einem Bot, in der Beta,
wer Beta gespielt hat, ihr kennt doch Orbital oben auf dem, der Heli-Platz auf dem Hochhaus,
der Heli-Platz auf dem Hochhaus, da gehen ja vorne so Treppen runter in das Treppenhaus,
da gehen ja vorne und ich hab die ein bisschen abgecampt und auf einmal seh ich halt unten
guck nen Bot um die Ecke und wirft mir ne Granate direkt an den Kopf, die explodiert.
Also ich hab den Bot für ein Pixel gesehen und es ist direkt mir ne Granate an den Kopf
geflogen, also die Bots sind teilweise ins Game eingebaute Cheats, aber davon abgesehen
in den restlichen Fällen waren die Bots komplett useless.
Bots ist eh die dümmste Idee, ich hasse Bots, wirklich ich mag auch das überhaupt nicht,
das war eines meiner größten Kritikpunkte, die ich da oben beim Video angesprochen hab,
diese Bot-Geschichte, ich find das so dämlich, ich will keine Bots killen in der Multiplayer
Match, wenn ich nicht in eine Bot Lobby gehe.
Du bist halt mehr damit beschäftigt, auf diese blöden KI Soldaten zu ballern, als auf andere
Spieler.
ALs auch das haut nicht so richtig hin, das sind alles Sachen, die man mit Patches hat.
Die werden aber gerek'kt hier...
diesem Live-Service-Modell die treu zu halten, kann Hazard Zone noch ein sehr, sehr cooler
Modus werden. Aber aktuell ist das bloß von der Idee geil und in wenigen Momenten, wenn es dann
mal läuft. Aber da gibt es einfach noch viel, sehr viel Strecke auf dem Weg hin, ein Warzone-Killer.
Woran ist er jetzt gestorben? Wurde er gesnipet oder was?
Das heißt also meine zweite Frage wäre jetzt gewesen, ob sich das denn als dritter,
fester Modus so etablieren kann neben eben dem All-Out-Warfare. Aber da ist es jetzt im
gegenwärtigen Zustand. Also Hazard Zone ist eher Monarch-S. Warum ist das Ding eigentlich
nicht Free-to-Play? Das würde so viele Leute zu dem Game bringen. Na gut, dafür müsste man
das aber halt auch ordentlich supporten. Also ich meine Hazard Zone, warum ist das nicht Free-to-Play?
Na gut, das haben sich die EA-Stonks-Leute schon überlegt. Und man muss auch sagen,
weil die beiden anderen Modi einfach viel besser sind. Das war es ja auch was Gutes.
Dann kommen wir doch gleich zum dritten Modus und einigen der Modi, der zumindest,
wenn ich den Kommentaren unter unseren letzten Videos folgen darf, dann ist das der Modus,
auf den die Leute den meisten Bock haben, nämlich Battlefield Portal. Also der Modus,
in dem man die alten Battlefields mit den neuen kombinieren kann. Erklär doch mal kurz,
wie das funktioniert. Ja, Battlefield Portal ist der Hammer. Das werfe ich nur schon mal von
vornherein. Also der hat mir wirklich sehr gut gefallen. Es gibt im Prinzip zwei Seiten von
dieser Battlefield-Portal-Medalien. Die eine Seite ist ein Editor, mit dem ihr theoretisch
alle möglichen Traum-Matches erschaffen könnt. Ihr könnt natürlich jetzt keine eigenen Karten
bauen. Leider. Aber ihr könnt zum Beispiel sagen, ich will einen Free-for-All-Metal. Ich weiß nicht,
ob wir morgen im Stream dazu kommen, aber ich will diesen Logik-Editor mal ausprobieren in Portal,
ob man damit wirklich Sachen, ich denke es mal, programmieren kann oder nicht. Wo alle nur eine
Bazooka mit einer Patrone haben und man lädt nach, indem man springt. Das ist ein Modus,
den DICE uns gegeben hat, den wir 40 Minuten lang spielen mussten, was sehr schnell keinen
Spaß mehr gemacht hat. Es gibt hier einen richtigen Editor, mit dem man sehr viel machen kann, wo man
echt abwarten muss, ob das was ist, was zündet. Also diese Custom-Modi, das sind halt sehr oft
so Quatsch-Sachen und DICE hat uns jetzt auch wirklich mit einem Free-for-All, wo alle einfach
nur aufeinanderballern auf einer kleinen Karte. Hier ist nicht wirklich was Kreatives an die Hand
gegeben. Ich bin aber auch kein Freund von solchen Quatsch-Modi. Ich mag sowas nicht. Aber es gibt
diese andere Seite der Medaille. Also bis jetzt gibt es keine Echtgeld-Sachen, die Vorteile
bringen und sie sagen auch, das wird es nicht geben. Aber mal ganz ehrlich, es wurde schon viel gesagt
in der Vergangenheit, weil der Tag lang ist. Das war der Hammer. Das war so cool, El Alamein in
aktueller Grafik zu spielen und da mit einem Panzer durch die Wüste zu tuckern. Es war so cool,
Valparaiso zu spielen, die Bad Company 2 Maps zu spielen, Battlefield 3 zu spielen. Endlich
wieder ein Nose-Hair-Spiel. Man hat dann eben auch die klassischen Soldaten mit den klassischen
Waffen. Also da stecken dann viel, viel mehr Waffen drin, als in dem ursprünglichen Battlefield 2042.
Das macht unheimlich Spaß. Ist Battlefield besser oder kot, kann man nicht so einfach sagen. Vor
allem nicht, wenn ein Spiel erst morgen rauskommt. Cool und so, aber diese klassischen Karten, das ist
eigentlich, wo es abgeht. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Fan bin von sagen wir mal nur Bad
Company, bekomme ich dann hier genug geboten? Ne, noch ist es zu wenig. Ganz kleine Auswahl Bad
Company. Wenn ich nur das spielen will, dann habe ich innerhalb von zwei Wochen eigentlich nichts mehr
zu tun. Ja, also du hast halt jetzt einen sehr eingeschränkten Map-Pool aktuell pro Spiel. Also
du kannst jetzt nicht erwarten, dass du einfach Bad Company 2 den Multiplayer noch mal in seiner
Gänze spielen kannst in Battlefield Portal. Aber du kannst eben, ich glaube zwei Maps von Battlefield
Company 2 spielen in diesem klassischen Spielmodi. Warum sieht er das noch mal erleben? Warum ist
der Gegner eigentlich durch die Wand gespottet? Das ist Bad Company 2, da gab es sowas nicht.
Warum ist er, was ist der Grund, warum man den durch die Wand sieht?
Battlefield Company 2 spielen in diesem klassischen Spielmodus. Ah, Eliminate Enemy VIP, das ist noch ein
spezieller Spielmodus. Ah ja, okay. Und da halt einfach das noch mal erleben. Also das ist jetzt
natürlich ein Mix, ein Best-of. Alter, mach ihn doch jetzt mal platt. Das kann man fast sagen, aus klassischen
Modi. Das ist ergänzend gedacht zur Battlefield 2042 Erfahrung. Es kann sein, dass wenn das jetzt
haufenweise neue Karten bekommt, wie in einem Jahr hier sitzen und dann kannst du echt sagen, okay,
ich kann da halt so viel Battlefield Company 2 Karten spielen und die Maps sind auch wunderbar
zerstörbar, die Battlefield Company 2 Maps, was ich Hammer finde, dass das halt wirklich alleine
trägt, mir dieses Spiel zu kaufen. Jetzt aktuell verteilt es sich, also ich sollte schon Lust haben,
auch All-out Warfare auszuprobieren, auch die neuen Karten auszuprobieren. Nur für Portal glaube ich
auch nicht, dass sich das lohnt. Wir müssen natürlich noch irgendwie eine Art von abschließendem
Fazit da zu finden. Also du hattest jetzt schon die Stärken und Schwächen der einzelnen Modi,
das Portal eigentlich ganz cool ist, aber vielleicht nicht so viel, dass All-out Warfare mit
die Specialist jetzt dann doch besser funktionieren als gedacht. Wie ist denn so denn insgesamt dein
Fazit für all die, die jetzt quasi noch auf dem Zaun sitzen, vielleicht sogar das Spiel jetzt
vorbestellen, um früher reinzukommen oder es halt am 19. zu kaufen. Würdest du das empfehlen oder
sollen die Leute lieber noch warten? Ich habe da keine leichten, simplen Antworten. Also ich
würde empfehlen, einfach zu warten. Ich habe es eh schon im Origin-Account. Wie wirken sich die Bugs aus?
Ist es realistisch, dass das Spiel mit eurer Grafikkarte läuft? Wie schnell kommen die Patches? Also
zumindest mal diesen Release-Speed noch abzuwarten. Ihr verliert ja nichts. Es ist ja jetzt auch eh
noch Pre-Season-Phase. Also die erste Saison beginnt ja erst, wo man dann Battle Pass
freischreiben kann. Ich hoffe, DICE schafft diesmal die eigene Zeitpläne zu halten. Also wenn man auf
der sicheren Seite bleiben will... Ist da Motion? Ist da Motionblur an? Oder sieht das jetzt immer
im Video so aus? Also wenn man auf der sicheren Seite bleiben will, sollte man da vielleicht noch
abwarten. Lieber über Steam oder Origin kaufen? Boah, kann ich dir nicht sagen. Ich muss mal gucken,
wo es an... Ich habe keine Ahnung. Es gibt bestimmt wieder irgendwelche Tricks. Wahrscheinlich ist
irgendwie zum Testen irgendeinem EA Play, aber für 3€ eh besser. 2240 ist auch jetzt kein schlechtes
Spiel. Man kann damit sehr viel Spaß haben. Ich glaube nur, über das Schicksal dieses Spiels wird
erst in den nächsten Wochen entschieden werden. Das glaube ich auch. Ob DICE halt schnell Sachen
liefert. Ja, korrekt. Genau das. Da möchte ich jetzt mal sagen, um auf... Ich will jetzt nicht
alles nochmal wiederholen, aber genau das habe ich mich hier auch darüber ausgelassen. Das ist
wichtig. Die müssen Postrelease-Content liefern und die müssen Postrelease-Support liefern. Also
von Patches bis mit Bugs zu Balancing, sonst was und halt regelmäßig auch neuen Content. Wenn
die der Meinung sind, jetzt ein Spiel zu releasen und das nächste halbe Jahr über kaum was dran zu
machen, dann ist es dead. Content nachpatchen, sich schnell um Probleme kümmern. Das ist die
eine Sache, womit sie sich... Ja, wahrscheinlich ist das so. Das ist bei allen Battlefields so,
dass Steam Origin startet und Origin startet das Game. Das haben sie immer schwer getan in den
letzten 7-8 Jahren. Deswegen würde ich da nicht so viel Vorschussvertrauen investieren, sondern
einfach abwarten. Und was man daran übrigens auch witzigerweise schön sieht, ist ein Riesenteam. Da
haben ja was weiß ich, 50.000... Ey, das ist jetzt übertrieben. Ich sage jetzt einfach nochmal,
50.000 Leute dran gearbeitet. Das ist massig. Dass das nicht zwangsläufig zu einem super polished,
mega umfangreichem Spiel führen muss. Aber es ist die sichere Antwort. Es ist ja schließlich unser
aller Geld. Ja, nachdem wir jetzt quasi in den letzten Videos zur Beta und so auch eher versucht
haben, das optimistisch zu sehen und jetzt eben doch in der Release-Version das ein oder andere
Problem weiterhin besteht, ist es tatsächlich die bessere Variante jetzt erstmal warten und dann
sollen die erstmal liefern. Gut, dann danke ich dir, Demi, für den Eindruck von diesem Test-Event.
Wenn ihr jetzt noch mehr zu Battlefield 2042 erfahren wollt, dann schaut natürlich auf
GameStar.de vorbei. Alles klar, exzell. War doch ein gutes Video. Habe ich vieles von dem,
was ich mir gedacht habe, bestätigt. Aber gucken uns das morgen selbst an. Alles klar,
schon spät, Leute. Bedge. Bedge-Time. Cyrus, danke nochmal für den Host. Bin jetzt aber schon weg.
Wir sehen uns. Schauen, ob ich irgendjemand hosten kann. Nein, glaube ich, keiner da.
Alles klar, bis dann. See you.